Thank you. your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. 18-year-old Gudmundur Einarsson took a final swig from his bottle of brandy. He looked once more around the packed nightclub for his friends. Located in the small fishing town of Habnafjallur, 17 kilometres south of Guthmundur's home in Blessegrof, Iceland, the nightclub was buzzing for a Saturday. Most of the town's younger population were present, dancing and drinking their night away. Guthmunda had been partying all day and when it was time to leave the club, his friends were nowhere to be seen. Assuming they had deserted him for the company of a group of girls, Guthmunda left the bar.
谢谢。这是您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您使用的应用程序或我们网站上的本集节目简介。18 岁的古德蒙杜尔·埃纳尔松（Gudmundur Einarsson）喝下了最后一口白兰地。他再次环顾拥挤的夜总会寻找他的朋友。这家夜总会位于哈布纳菲厄泽（Habnafjallur）这个小渔镇，距离古德蒙杜尔位于冰岛布莱塞格罗夫（Blessegrof）的家以南 17 公里，星期六的晚上这里十分热闹。镇上的大部分年轻人都在这里，跳舞饮酒度过良宵。古德蒙杜尔一整天都在狂欢，当到了离开夜店的时候，他的朋友们却不见了踪影。古德蒙杜尔以为他们抛下自己去追几个女孩了，于是便离开了酒吧。
Inebriated, Guthmunda was escorted outside by an older man he had befriended earlier in the night. The weather changed considerably from the time Gutmunder entered the nightclub to his exit in the early morning of Sunday January 27 1974. The light drizzle of rain had given way to a furious snowstorm. Wind howled through the streets and the temperature dropped to below freezing as snow blanketed the footpaths and the roads turned icy. Iceland was short on nightlife, so Gudmundur had walked to get to the club. He was now facing the prospect of a three-hour return trip at 2am in hazardous conditions. Gutmunder's companion was wearing a bright yellow shirt that stood out amongst the white snowfall. The pair decided to try their luck at attracting a vehicle to hitchhike home.
古德蒙杜尔醉醺醺地被他在当晚早些时候结识的一名年长男子护送到了外面。从古德蒙杜尔进入夜总会到他在 1974 年 1 月 27 日星期日清晨离开，天气发生了巨大的变化。原本的毛毛细雨已经变成了狂暴的风雪。风在街道呼啸，气温骤降至冰点以下，雪花覆盖了小路，道路变得结冰。冰岛的夜生活很少，所以古德蒙杜尔是步行去的夜总会。现在他面临着在凌晨 2 点恶劣的天气下步行三个小时返回的处境。古德蒙杜尔的同伴穿着一件在白雪中格外醒目的明黄色衬衫。两人决定碰碰运气，看能否拦到车搭便车回家。
Elimborg Rabsdottir and her friendridha Magnusdotter drove past the men. Elimborg recognised Gudmundur in his checkered jacket, green pants and brown shoes. She pulled over to offer him a lift. As she slowed down, Gudmundur's new friend threw himself onto the bonnet of their vehicle in a drunken state. Deterred by his behaviour, the two women changed their mind and refused to let them in. A few hours later, a driver passed Guthmunder walking on the main road out of Habnafjorda towards his family home in Blessegrof. He was alone and stumbling, almost falling in front of the car as it drove by. The man passed to Gudmundur and kept his concentration on the road ahead as it continued to snow heavily.
埃利姆博格·拉布斯多蒂尔（Elimborg Rabsdottir）和她的朋友丽达·马格努斯多蒂尔（fridha Magnusdotter）开车从两人身边驶过。埃利姆博格认出了穿着格纹夹克、绿色裤子和棕色鞋子的古德蒙杜尔。她靠边停车打算载他一程。当她放慢车速时，古德蒙杜尔的新朋友醉醺醺地扑到了他们的车的前发动机盖上。两名女子被他的行为吓退，改变了主意，拒绝让他们上车。几个小时后，一名司机路过正在从哈布纳菲厄泽沿着主路步行回布莱塞格罗夫家里的古德蒙杜尔。他独自一人，步履蹒跚，在车开过时差点摔倒在车前。这名司机从古德蒙杜尔身边开过，由于雪下得很大，他继续集中精力看着前方的道路。
Following this sighting, Gudmundur Einarsson vanished. Initially assuming he was staying with friends, Guthmundur's father was unconcerned by his son's absence. When two days passed with no word from his son, his feelings changed and he reported Gudmundur missing. In 1974, the population of Iceland was just over 215,000 people. Homicide was nearly an unheard of event. Given the inclement weather on the night of Guthmundr's disappearance, combined with his clean police record, police were quick to rule out foul play
目击这次出行后，古德蒙杜尔·埃纳尔松便失踪了。古德蒙杜尔的父亲起初以为他和朋友待在一起，因此对儿子的缺席并不担心。当两天过去仍没有儿子的音讯时，他的心情变了，并报案称古德蒙杜尔失踪。1974 年，冰岛的总人口刚超过 21.5 万人。谋杀案几乎是闻所未闻的事件。鉴于古德蒙杜尔失踪当晚的天气恶劣，加上他干净的无犯罪记录，警方很快排除了他杀的可能性。
Rather, they assumed that Guthmundr had either gotten disorientated and lost, or had injured himself, perhaps fatally, on the journey home A barren expanse of lava fields, the landscape outside of Habnafjorda was covered with craters and crevices. Some reached a depth of 30 metres. Due to the snowstorm, 60 centimetres of fresh snow had fallen in the past few days, further concealing the fissures in the ground. Over 200 people searched for Gutmunder in the less than favourable conditions. Some waded waist-deep in snow, while a helicopter circled the lava fields from above. Isolated roads leading to his friends' houses were checked, as well as sheds and outhouses in case Guthmundur had sought shelter during the storm.
相反，他们推测古德蒙杜尔可能是在回家的路上迷失了方向，或者受了伤，甚至可能是致命伤。哈布纳菲厄泽郊外的地貌是一片贫瘠的熔岩原，布满了火山口和裂缝。有些深度达到了 30 米。由于暴风雪，过去几天降下了 60 厘米的新雪，进一步掩盖了地面的裂缝。200 多人在不太有利的条件下搜寻古德蒙杜尔。一些人在没腰深的雪中跋涉，而一架直升机则在熔岩原上方盘旋。通往他朋友家人的偏僻道路受到了检查，棚屋和附属建筑也遭到了搜查，以防古德蒙杜尔在暴风雨期间寻求庇护。
Those who had seen Guthmundur on the day of his disappearance could do little to shed light on his whereabouts. A week after Guthmundur disappeared, the snow began to melt. The search party returned to the lava fields to continue scouring the landscape. There was no sign of him. The man in the yellow shirt who left the nightclub with Gutmundur was never identified. Weeks and months passed by. It was not uncommon for people to go missing in the unforgiving terrain of the Icelandic lava fields or accidentally drown in rough seas off the country's rocky cliff faces. As time went on, Gudmundur's family came to terms with the fact
那些在古德蒙杜尔失踪当天见过他的人对于他的下落提供不了什么线索。古德蒙杜尔失踪一周后，积雪开始融化。搜寻队重返熔岩原继续搜寻这片土地。没有他的踪迹。那个穿着黄衬衫、和古德蒙杜尔一起离开夜总会的男子一直没有被认出。几周和几个月过去了。在冰岛熔岩原无情的地形中失踪，或者在国家崎岖的悬崖边遭遇海浪意外溺水，对于人们来说并不罕见。随着时间的推移，古德蒙杜尔的家人逐渐接受了这样一个事实：
that he was yet another person who went missing amongst the unforgiving Icelandic wilderness. yet another person who went missing amongst the unforgiving Icelandic wilderness. With no leads to go on, detectives also reached this conclusion and the case was closed. In December 1973, a month before Gudmundur's disappearance, 18-year-old Erla Bolladolta attended a house party in Reykjavik. A free spirit enthralled by the recent hippie influences that had reached the shores of Iceland, Erla often visited the communes around the area to party, dance, smoke cannabis, and listen to rock music with like-minded teens. At the party, Erla was drinking a glass of cola when she began to feel strange. She realised her drink had been spiked
他不过是在无情的冰岛荒野中又一个失踪的人。在没有任何线索的情况下，侦探们也得出了这个结论，案件被结案。1973 年 12 月，即古德蒙杜尔失踪前一个月，18 岁的埃拉·博拉多尔塔（Erla Bolladolta）参加了雷克雅未克的一个家庭派对。作为一个被最近吹拂到冰岛海岸的嬉皮士思潮所迷住的自由灵魂，埃拉经常去该地区的公社参加派对、跳舞、吸食大麻，并与志同道合的青少年一起听摇滚乐。在派对上，埃拉正喝着一杯可乐，突然开始感到有些不对劲。她意识到自己的饮料被下药了
with the hallucinogenic drug LSD. Erla explored the house, looking for somewhere quiet to rest until the effects of the drug had worn off. In a darkened room, she tripped over a man lying on the floor. He introduced himself as 18-year-old Saevar Ciesielski. He was also riding out an LSD trip after his drink had been spiked. Together, the two lay in the darkness and spoke about their lives. Saevar was a child of an American-Polish father and an Icelandic mother. His foreign-sounding name, combined with his slight frame and short stature, made him a target for bullies during his school years. With dyslexia and ADHD, Saevar had trouble concentrating
被迷幻药 LSD 下了药。埃拉在房子里寻找一个安静的地方休息，直到药效消退。在一个黑暗的房间里，她被一个躺在地上的男人绊倒了。他自我介绍说自己是 18 岁的萨瓦尔·西谢尔斯基（Saevar Ciesielski）。他的饮料也被下药了，同样正处于 LSD 的幻觉中。两人一起躺在黑暗中，谈论着各自的生活。萨瓦尔是一位美国波兰裔父亲和冰岛母亲的孩子。他带有异国情调的名字，加上他单薄的身材和矮小的个头，使他在学生时代成为了霸凌的目标。患有诵读困难症和多动症的萨瓦尔很难集中注意力
at school. When he was 14, a psychiatrist recommended that he be sent to a home for delinquent boys. At the home, the boys were expected to do farm work, complete schooling, and return to their parents completely reformed. After a few years, Saevar went back to his family in Reykjavik. The home did little to transform Saevar. Although very intelligent, he spent his late teen years committing petty crimes such as theft and drug smuggling with his friend Christian. Years later, the boys' home Saevar attended was shut down amid allegations from past students about physical abuse and rape that had occurred behind closed doors. Erla was drawn to Saevar as he spoke of his history. She found his foreign look,
在学校里。在他 14 岁时，一位精神病医生建议把他送到一个问题少年收容所。在那里，男孩们被期望从事农场工作，完成学业，并彻底改造后回到父母身边。几年后，萨瓦尔回到了位于雷克雅未克的家人身边。这家收容所对萨瓦尔的改造收效甚微。尽管他非常聪明，但他的青少年晚期却和朋友克里斯蒂安（Christian）一起度过，从事盗窃和走私毒品等轻微犯罪活动。多年后，萨瓦尔曾就读的少年收容所因往届学生指控闭门造车背后发生虐待和强奸而关闭。埃拉被讲述自己过往经历的萨瓦尔所吸引。她发现他具有异国情调的外表，
with shoulder-length brown hair, intense brown eyes and delicate features, mysterious and attractive. Erla also opened up about her life. She was the middle child of three. As a child, her family lived in New York where her father worked as a station manager for Iceland Air at Kennedy Airport. Her family returned home to Iceland when Erla was seven and she spent her childhood years at the local school. On school holidays, she was sent to various farms around Iceland to assist as a farmhand, a common tradition for Icelandic families at the time. After being touched inappropriately by a farmer, Erla returned home a changed girl. She became withdrawn from her family and rebelled against her parents. from her family and rebelled against her parents. Erla's parents divorced and as a teen, after a fight with her mother about curfew times, Erla went to live with her father. Erla empathised
肩长的棕色头发、深邃的棕色眼睛和精致的五官，既神秘又迷人。埃拉也敞开心扉谈论了自己的生活。她是三个孩子中的老二。小时候，她的家人住在纽约，父亲在那里担任冰岛航空在肯尼迪机场的站长。埃拉七岁时全家返回冰岛，她在当地学校度过了童年时光。在学校假期里，她被派往冰岛各地的农场担任农场帮工，这是当时冰岛家庭的常见传统。在遭到一名农民的不当抚摸后，埃拉回家后像变了一个人。她开始疏远家人，并对父母进行叛逆。从她的家人那里疏远并反叛父母。埃拉的父母离婚了，十几岁时，在与母亲就门禁时间吵了一架后，埃拉去和父亲一起生活。埃拉产生了共鸣
with Saevar and found his love of the arts, particularly film, music and painting, fascinating and exciting. They spoke until morning. Erla later commented in the documentary Out of Thin Air, After that night, there was no other way to go forward but together. Erla's mother was less than impressed that her daughter was dating a former student from a home for delinquent boys and forbade him from entering her house. Despite warnings from her family that Saevar was a dangerous man, Erla quickly fell in love. Saevar and Erla were inseparable. Saevar and Erla were inseparable. Saevar often spent time at Erla and her father's house in Habnerfjorda, a small white and red-roofed apartment on Hammersbrod Road. At the time, Erla worked for the telegraph service as a clerk. Shortly after moving in with her father in early 1974, he had a stroke and was hospitalised, leaving Erla to live alone for the first time in her life.
与萨瓦尔产生了共鸣，并发现他对艺术的热爱，尤其是电影、音乐和绘画，既迷人又令人兴奋。他们一直聊到早晨。埃拉后来在纪录片《凭空消失》（Out of Thin Air）中评论道：“从那天晚上起，我们只有一条路可走，那就是一起走。”埃拉的母亲对女儿和一个问题少年收容所的前学生约会感到很不高兴，并禁止他进入她的家。尽管家人警告说萨瓦尔是个危险人物，但埃拉还是迅速坠入爱河。萨瓦尔和埃拉形影不离。萨瓦尔和埃拉形影不离。萨瓦尔经常待在埃拉和她父亲位于哈布纳菲厄泽的家中，那是汉默斯布罗德路上一间带红瓦的小白公寓。当时，埃拉在电报局担任职员。1974 年初搬去和父亲同住不久后，他中风住院了，这让埃拉平生第一次独自生活。
Working long hours, Erla became profoundly depressed and lonely. Saevar would disappear for days at a time, refusing to explain his absences to her when he returned. She was certain he was seeing other women. Erla spent her time off work lying in bed staring out the window for the entirety of the day. Her weight plummeted and her long blonde hair accentuated her pale face and dark under-eye circles. When Saevar was around, he spoke constantly about wanting to pull off the perfect crime. He boasted about the joy he would get from the Icelandic authorities not being able to figure out who did it. to figure out who did it. Bank robberies, petty theft, smuggling drugs and introducing LSD into the water supply were some of the crimes he fantasised about.
由于长时间工作，埃拉变得极度抑郁和孤独。萨瓦尔会一连失踪几天，回来时也拒绝向她解释他不在的原因。她确信他在和别的女人鬼混。埃拉把不工作的时间都用来躺在床上一整天盯着窗外。她的体重暴跌，金色的长头发更衬托出她苍白的脸和深重的黑眼圈。当萨瓦尔在身边时，他总是不停地谈论想要实施完美的犯罪。他吹嘘自己从冰岛当局无法查出是谁干的这件事中获得的快乐。来弄清楚是谁干的。银行抢劫、小偷小摸、走私毒品以及把 LSD 投进供水系统都是他幻想的一些罪行。
Easily led by Saevar and wanting to impress him, Erla and Saevar hatched the perfect plan. Erla's work at the telegraph service gave her a thorough knowledge of the procedures in Iceland for transferring money over the phone. Saevar obtained a fake woman's ID with a false name and photograph. Erla and Saevar then picked apart the telephone receiver at her house, shoving a cloth into the mouthpiece. When Erla then phoned the National Phone Company's Telegraph Reception Centre with a fake name, her voice was muffled, giving the impression that the phone call was being placed from far away.
在萨瓦尔的轻易引导下，并且为了给他留下深刻印象，埃拉和萨瓦尔密谋了一个完美的计划。埃拉在电报局的工作让她对冰岛通过电话转账的程序有了透彻的了解。萨瓦尔搞到了一张带有假名字和照片的女性假身份证。随后，埃拉和萨瓦尔拆开了她家的电话听筒，把一块布塞进了话筒里。当埃拉随后用假名给国家电话公司电报接待中心打电话时，她的声音变得沉闷，给人一种电话是从很远的地方打来的印象。
She told the operator that she was from a post office in the south-west of Iceland and was placing a money order on behalf of a customer there A few days later, a female friend of Saevar's went to collect the money with a fake ID, showing the name Erla had given the telegraph centre Together, Erla and Saeva made off with just under half a million krona, or approximately 5,000 Australian dollars in today's currency Pleased with themselves, they repeated the scam Erla dared to collect the money herself, applying heavy makeup so she resembled the photo ID she held With shaking hands, she gave the ID to the post office clerk. After a few moments, the clerk smiled and went to retrieve the money. Again, the pair had netted themselves just under half a million kroner. Unsure of what to do with the money, they stashed it in a cupboard in Erla's bedroom.
她告诉接线员她来自冰岛西南部的一个邮局，并代表那里的客户下达汇款单几天后，萨瓦尔的一位女性朋友拿着假身份证去取钱，上面显示的是埃拉给电报中心的名字。埃拉和萨瓦尔携手卷走了不到五十万克朗，按今天的货币计算大约合 5,000 澳元。他们对自己的成果感到满意，于是又重复了这个骗局。埃拉甚至大着胆子自己去取钱，她化了浓妆，让自己看起来像她拿着的那张身份证上的照片。她双手颤抖着把身份证交给了邮局职员。片刻之后，职员微笑着去取钱。这一次，两人又轻轻松松捞到了不到五十万克朗。由于不知道该怎么处理这笔钱，他们把它藏在埃拉卧室的一个柜子里。
However, it wasn't long before the missing money was noticed and reported to authorities. Tuesday November 19 1974 marked 10 months after the disappearance of Gudmundur Einarsson. That day, 32-year-old Geirfinna Einarsson finished work and headed to his home in Keblavik, Iceland. A small fishing community, Keblavik lay approximately 40 kilometres west of where Guthmunder was last seen. Although both men shared the surname Einarsson, they were unrelated and had never met. Unlike Guthmunder, the 18-year-old apprentice carpenter who loved to party and whose friendly nature never left him short of friends, Geofina was much more reserved. Fourteen years his senior, Geofina was a quiet man who worked hard as a manual labourer
然而，没过多久，这笔失踪的钱就被注意到了，并被报告给当局。1974 年 11 月 19 日星期二，标志着古德蒙杜尔·埃纳尔松失踪满 10 个月。那天，32 岁的盖尔芬纳·埃纳尔松（Geirfinna Einarsson）下班后前往他在冰岛凯夫拉维克（Keblavik）的家。凯夫拉维克是一个小渔村，位于古德蒙杜尔最后一次被目击地点以西约 40 公里处。尽管两人的姓氏都是埃纳尔松，但他们没有亲属关系，也从未见过面。与古德蒙杜尔不同，后者是一个喜欢聚会、生性友善且从不缺朋友的 18 岁木工学徒，盖尔芬纳则要内向得多。比他年长十四岁的盖尔芬纳是一个沉默寡言的人，他作为体力劳动者辛勤工作
and enjoyed spending spare time with his young family. Returning home, Geofina and his family ate dinner together. Geofina, tired from a hard day's work, went to bed to read a book. His wife went to the library. She returned home at approximately 8.30 to find Geofinna in the company of his friend Thordr. Both men were watching television and drinking coffee. Both men were watching television and drinking coffee. Geirfinnur told Þorðar that he had some people to meet and asked if he could get a ride.
并喜欢把闲暇时间留给年轻的家人。回到家后，盖尔芬纳和家人一起吃了晚饭。盖尔芬纳因一天的辛苦工作而感到疲惫，便上床去看书了。他的妻子去了图书馆。她于大约 8 点 30 分回家，发现盖尔芬纳正和他的朋友索尔杜尔（Thordr）在一起。两人都在看电视、喝咖啡。两人都在看电视、喝咖啡。盖尔芬纳告诉索尔杜尔他有几个人要见，并问他能不能搭便车。
He wanted to go to a cafe near the Keblavík docks. The pair departed at around 10pm. Geirfinnur was quiet during the car ride, declining to elaborate on who he was seeing or the purpose of the meeting. As they drew nearer to Geirfinnur's destination, he remarked to Thorvar that he should be armed. His friend took the comment as a joke and dropped Geirfinnur at the doors of the near-deserted cafe. and dropped the geofina at the doors of the near-deserted café. Geofina scanned the few patrons seated inside. The people he was looking for weren't there. Walking home in the cold, crisp air, Geofina opened the front door and heard his son pick up the ringing telephone.
他想去凯夫拉维克码头附近的一家咖啡馆。两人于晚上 10 点左右出发。盖尔芬纳在车程中很安静，拒绝详细说明他要见谁或会面的目的。当他们越来越接近盖尔芬纳的目的地时，他对索瓦尔（Thorvar）说他应该带上武器。他的朋友把这句话当成了一个玩笑，把盖尔芬纳放在了几乎荒芜的咖啡馆门前。并将盖尔芬纳放下，在几乎荒芜的咖啡馆门前。盖尔芬纳扫视了坐在里面的几位顾客。他要找的人不在那里。盖尔芬纳在清冷新鲜的空气中走回家，推开前门，听到儿子接起了正在响的电话。
It was 10.15pm. The deep male voice on the line asked to speak to Geirfinnur and his son dutifully handed over the phone. Geirfinnur explained to the caller that he had already been to the cafe before sighing and replying that he had already been to the café, before sighing and replying that he would return once again. Geyerfinner's son asked if he could accompany his father, who abruptly denied the request. This time driving himself, Geyerfinner parked his red Ford Cortina 200 metres from the entrance.
当时是晚上 10 点 15 分。电话那头低沉的男声要求与盖尔芬纳通话，他的儿子尽职尽责地把电话递了过去。盖尔芬纳向来电者解释说他已经去过那家咖啡馆了，随后叹了口气，回答说他已经去过咖啡馆了，并叹了口气回答说他会再次回去。盖尔芬纳的儿子问他是否可以陪父亲去，但父亲生硬地拒绝了这个请求。这一次盖尔芬纳自己开车，把他的红色福特科蒂纳停在距离入口 200 米的地方。
He turned the engine off and left the keys in the ignition before making his way back to the cafe. His unlocked car was found the next day in the same position by detectives, after Geirfinner's wife had reported him missing. The investigation offered little more in the way of clues than Gutmunder's disappearance had 10 months prior. However, unlike Gutmunder, Keblavik police believed immediately that Geirfinnur had met with foul play due to his unexplained disappearance following a mysterious meeting. Police appealed for those who had arranged to meet with Gayafina to come forward, but their requests went unanswered. A tracking dog latched on to Gayafina's scent but stopped abruptly outside the cafe, indicating that he had travelled in a car to another location. Patrons in the cafe at the time of Gayafina's disappearance were questioned.
他熄灭了发动机，把钥匙留在点火开关里，然后折返回咖啡馆。盖尔芬纳的妻子报案称他失踪后，侦探们第二天在同一位置找到了他没锁的车。这次调查提供的线索并不比 10 个月前古德蒙杜尔失踪时多多少。然而，与古德蒙杜尔不同的是，由于盖尔芬纳在一次神秘的会面后莫名失踪，凯夫拉维克警方立即认定他遭遇了不测。警方呼吁那些与盖尔芬纳约定见面的人主动站出来，但他们的请求石沉大海。一只追踪犬咬住了盖尔芬纳的气味，但在咖啡馆外突然停了下来，这表明他曾坐车去了另一个地方。盖尔芬纳失踪时在咖啡馆里的顾客受到了讯问。
Several noted a man making a call from a phone booth inside the cafe at approximately 10.15pm. Normally, this would not have drawn anyone's attention. However, everyone in Keblavik knew one another, and this man was an out-of-towner. Investigators speculated that this was the man who had called to arrange the rendezvous with Geofinner. The man in the phone booth was described as 180 centimetres tall, slim, wearing a fake leather jacket and light-coloured pants. A bust was made out of
几个人注意到，大约晚上 10 点 15 分，一名男子正在咖啡馆内的电话亭打电话。通常情况下，这不会引起任何人的注意。然而，凯夫拉维克的所有人都互相认识，而这个人是个外地人。调查人员推测，此人就是打电话安排与盖尔芬纳会面的人。据描述，电话亭里的男子身高 180 厘米，身材苗条，穿着一件人造皮夹克和浅色裤子。一个半身像是由
clay depicting the physical attributes of the unknown man. It was shown on national TV and soon Keblevik police were inundated with people reporting those who resembled a likeness to the image. Meanwhile, detectives worked on the theory that Geirfinna might not have been as reserved and innocent as people suspected. In 1974, beer greater than two and a quarter percent in alcoholic strength was banned throughout Iceland, and alcohol in general was very expensive. As a result, beer and spirits would often be smuggled in. The most common exchange would take place offshore. Watertight plastic containers were thrown from large ships into small boats who took them back
泥土塑成，描绘了这名身份不明的男子的身体特征。它在全国电视上播出，不久凯夫拉维克警方就被那些报告长相酷似该图像的人的电话淹没了。与此同时，侦探们顺着一种理论展开工作，即盖尔芬纳可能不像人们猜测的那样内向和纯洁。1974 年，整个冰岛都禁止销售酒精度超过百分之二点二五的啤酒，而且总的来说酒非常贵。因此，啤酒和烈酒经常被走私进来。最常见的交易发生在近海。防水塑料容器从大船上扔到小船上，小船把它们带回
to the mainland. A person who knew Geirfinnur confessed that he was involved in smuggling alcohol into Iceland. This theory was further bolstered when someone rang the police to say that a man they knew resembled the clay bust. The man was local nightclub owner Magnus Leopoldsen. He had been seen speaking with Geirfinnur at his club, Kluberen, a few days prior to Geirfinnur's disappearance. Rumours circulated that Magnus also smuggled alcohol into Iceland. circulated that Magnus also smuggled alcohol into Iceland. Magnus Leopoldsen was questioned by police on January 25 1975.
大陆。一个认识盖尔芬纳的人供认他参与了向冰岛走私酒类的活动。当有人打电话给警方，称他们认识的一个人长得很像泥塑半身像时，这个理论得到了进一步的支撑。这个人是当地夜总会老板马格努斯·利奥波尔德森（Magnus Leopoldsen）。在盖尔芬纳失踪前几天，有人看到他在自己的夜总会 Kluberen 与盖尔芬纳交谈。有传言称马格努斯也将酒走私到冰岛。有传言称马格努斯也向冰岛走私酒类。马格努斯·利奥波尔德森于 1975 年 1 月 25 日遭到警方讯问。
However, he was free to go after no association could be made between him and the disappearance of Geirfinnur. Weeks went by. Desperate for a break in the case, a detective flew to Jordan with Geofina's wife to visit a psychic who claimed he could help solve the case. The week-long trip, funded by taxpayers, turned out to be a waste of time and money. Whilst police in Keblavik continued to investigate the disappearance of Geyerfinner, police in Reykjavik were busy tracing leads in an elaborate fraud involving money transfers to local post offices. Investigators questioned employees at the
然而，由于无法将他与盖尔芬纳的失踪联系起来，他被释放了。几个星期过去了。为了打破案件的僵局，一名侦探带着盖尔芬纳的妻子飞往约旦，拜访了一位声称能够帮助破案的灵媒。这次为期一周、由纳税人资助的旅行被证明是浪费时间和金钱。正当凯夫拉维克警方继续调查盖尔芬纳的失踪案时，雷克雅未克的警方正忙着追踪涉及向当地邮局转账的复杂诈骗案的线索。调查人员讯问了员工
Telegraph Centre and learned that one of their workers, Erla Bolledolter, was dating Saevar Ciesielski. He was well known to police for his past criminal history, which included smuggling cannabis from Denmark. Another time he had been arrested for stealing a large fish from the wharves and parading around town with it. Saevar's connection with the telegraph service through Erla was an immediate red flag, and investigators searched for their whereabouts. The couple had spent a brief time in Denmark before moving into a flat on the outskirts of Reykjavik. a flat on the outskirts of Reykjavik. The now 20-year-old Erla was thrilled when she found out she and Saeva were expecting a child. She told Saeva that her days of committing fraud were over
电报中心的工作人员，并得知他们的一个工人埃拉·博莱多尔特（Erla Bolledolter）正在和萨瓦尔·西谢尔斯基（Saevar Ciesielski）交往。他因过去的犯罪记录而在警方中广为人知，其中包括从丹麦走私大麻。还有一次，他因从码头上偷了一条大鱼并带着它在镇上游行而被捕。萨瓦尔通过埃拉与电报服务的联系是一个直接的危险信号，调查人员开始寻找他们的下落。这对夫妇在丹麦短暂停留了一段时间，然后搬进了雷克雅未克郊区的一间公寓。雷克雅未克郊区的一间公寓。现年 20 岁的埃拉得知自己和萨瓦尔即将迎来一个孩子时，欣喜若狂。她告诉萨瓦尔，她搞诈骗的日子已经结束了
and from now on she wanted to live a life free from any crime. The most important thing to her now was being a mother. The most important thing to her now was being a mother. Erla and Saevar's daughter was born in September. Three months later, on December 12, Saevar was arrested on suspicion of embezzlement regarding the money transfer scam. He was taken to Siedemullili prison in Reykjavík for questioning. The next day, Erla was also arrested for questioning. In disbelief that they had been caught, she handed her 11-week-old daughter to her sister to care for. On the way to prison, she told the police that she had to be back soon because her baby needed her.
从现在开始，她想过一种远离任何犯罪的生活。对她来说，现在最重要的是成为一个母亲。对她来说，现在最重要的是成为一个母亲。埃拉和萨瓦尔的女儿于 9 月出生。三个月后的 12 月 12 日，萨瓦尔因涉嫌挪用转账诈骗案而被捕。他被带到雷克雅未克的西德穆利（Siedemullili）监狱接受讯问。第二天，埃拉也被捕接受讯问。她不敢相信自己被抓了，便把 11 周大的女儿交由姐姐照顾。在去监狱的路上，她告诉警察她必须很快回去，因为她的婴儿需要她。
Iceland's Sædarmulli prison was a historic building located in Reykjavík's main shopping district. The exterior, built centuries ago from large, irregularly shaped rocks, housed the few prisoners in the Icelandic justice system. From the street, it could have been any other building, with no signage or fencing to indicate otherwise. Erla was taken through the front door and led down a corridor. The bright ceiling lights reflected off the linoleum floor. To either side of her, Erla could see the white bars of cell doors and inside the cells, the walls were painted a bright green. Each cell contained a concrete bed with a thin rubber mattress and a stool. Erla was led into an interrogation room for questioning
冰岛的赛达穆利（Sædarmulli）监狱是一座历史悠久的建筑，位于雷克雅未克的主要购物区。它的外观几个世纪前由大块不规则形状的岩石建成，关押着冰岛司法系统中的少数囚犯。从街上看，它可能与其他任何建筑没有区别，没有任何标牌或围栏来表明其特殊性。埃拉被带过前门，沿着一条走廊走去。明亮的吸顶灯反射着油毡地板。埃拉可以看到她两侧的白色牢房门，在牢房内部，墙壁被漆成鲜绿色。每个牢房里都有一张带薄橡胶床垫的混凝土床和一个凳子。埃拉被带进一间审讯室接受讯问
The room was tiny and cold and a small ceiling light shone onto the table where Erla was seated Three detectives sat opposite her In the corner sat a policeman at a typewriter, documenting Erla's every word Detectives told her that Saevar had come clean about the money fraud scam, but had implicated Erla as the sole perpetrator in the crime. Erla sat in silence. The detectives encouraged her to confess. Desperate to see her baby, Erla admitted her role in the crime. She signed a statement outlining her participation in the money fraud. Confident the interrogation was over, Erla straightened in preparation to leave. A detective then flashed a photograph in her face. It was of a young man with long
房间又小又冷，一盏小天花板灯照在埃拉坐着的桌子上。三名侦探坐在她对面。角落里坐着一名用打字机记录埃拉每一句话的警察。侦探们告诉她，萨瓦尔已经对金钱诈骗案全盘托出，但却暗示埃拉是这起犯罪的唯一主犯。埃拉坐在那里一言不发。侦探们鼓励她坦白。由于急于见到自己的孩子，埃拉承认了自己在犯罪中所扮演的角色。她签署了一份概述自己参与金钱诈骗的供词。确信审讯已经结束，埃拉挺直身子准备离开。这时，一名侦探把一张照片晃在她眼前。那是一个留着长发的年轻男子
black hair and dark eyes. He asked if she had known him. Erla recognised the man in the photo. It was 18-year-old Gudmundur Einarsson. She had met Gudmundur at a party years ago and remembered him because he was friendly and handsome. The detectives latched onto this information and the questioning continued for hours. Eventually, Erla gave up a secret she had been holding onto since the night of Gudmundur's disappearance, nearly two years prior. Erla remembered the night of Gudmundur's disappearance. She was in the midst of a depressive episode. A friend invited her to a party and Erla went reluctantly. Afterwards, she returned home to her father's apartment. The violent snowstorm had blanketed the ground outside the building in thick white snow. She remembered the scenery vividly. Certain that Saevar was out seeing another woman, Erla lay in bed trying to get some sleep.
黑头发，黑眼睛。他问她是否认识他。埃拉认出了照片里的男人。那是 18 岁的古德蒙杜尔·埃纳尔松。她几年前在一个派对上见过古德蒙杜尔，并记得他，因为他既友善又英俊。侦探们抓住了这条线索，盘问持续了几个小时。最终，埃拉吐露了一个她自古德蒙杜尔失踪之夜（近两年前）以来一直保守的秘密。埃拉还记得古德蒙杜尔失踪的那个夜晚。她正处于抑郁发作期。一位朋友邀请她去参加派对，埃拉勉强去了。之后，她回到父亲的公寓。猛烈的暴风雪将建筑物外的地面覆盖在厚厚的白雪中。她对那里的风景记忆犹新。埃拉确信萨瓦尔出去见别的女人了，便躺在床上试图入睡。
Later that night, she heard voices outside her window. They were whispering, but she could recognise two of them. One was Saevar, and the other was Saevar's friend, Christian Vithersen. Erla was intimidated by Christian. Saevar's friend, Christian Vithersen. Erla was intimidated by Christian. He was a petty criminal with a large, well-built frame and a reputation of being a tough guy. As Saevar only weighed 50 kilograms, the brutish Christian acted as his bodyguard. Erla didn't recognise the third voice, but was then startled when all the
那天深夜，她听到窗外传来声音。他们在窃窃私语，但她能认出其中两个人的声音。一个是萨瓦尔，另一个是萨瓦尔的朋友克里斯蒂安·维瑟森（Christian Vithersen）。埃拉对克里斯蒂安感到畏惧。萨瓦尔的朋友克里斯蒂安·维瑟森。埃拉对克里斯蒂安感到畏惧。他是一个身材高大魁梧、以硬汉著称的小罪犯。由于萨瓦尔只有 50 公斤重，粗暴的克里斯蒂安充当了他的保镖。埃拉没有认出第三个声音，但随后当所有人都
men came inside. After hours of questioning, Erla was exhausted and struggled to collect her thoughts. Detectives ceased the interrogation, offering Erla a night's reprieve in a prison cell to resume questioning the following morning. From the book The Reykjavik Confessions, the detectives listened the next day as Erla recounted what happened next, after the men had made their way inside her house. The police report read She made her way to the storage room where she saw Saevar, Christian and a third man with something heavy between them, covered in a sheet Christian and Saevar tied each end of the sheet with a knot Erla hadn't seen what was inside, but she thought it was a body There was also a foul smell in the room and a strange wet patch on the floor. The three men picked up the body,
男人们进来了。经过几个小时的讯问，埃拉筋疲力尽，难以集中思绪。侦探们停止了审讯，为埃拉提供了一晚在监狱牢房里的喘息机会，以便第二天早上恢复审讯。根据《雷克雅未克供词》（The Reykjavik Confessions）一书，侦探们第二天听着埃拉回忆接下来发生的事情，当时男人们已经进入了她的房子。警方报告写道：“她走到储藏室，看到萨瓦尔、克里斯蒂安和第三个男人手里拿着一件沉重的东西，上面盖着一张床单。克里斯蒂安和萨瓦尔用结把床单的两头系上。埃拉没看到里面是什么，但她认为是一具尸体。房间里还有一股难闻的气味，地上有一个奇怪的湿斑。三个男人抬起尸体，
pushing past her in the doorway and knocking her over. Erla recalled, I couldn't move. I was cold, but at the same time, I felt like I was sweating. Later, Saiba took me by the arms and put me to bed. I said I was going to deny everything. Erla told the detectives that the day after she went to the garbage bin outside her house and found a soiled bedsheet inside. It appeared to have been dumped there after Saevar, Christian and the third man had removed the body from the apartment. Over the course of the next few weeks, detectives continued to question Erla over the disappearance of Gudmundur Einarsson.
在门口挤过她身边，把她撞倒了。埃拉回忆说：“我动不了。我很冷，但同时，我觉得自己在流汗。”后来，赛巴抓住我的胳膊把我弄上床。我说我要否认一切。”埃拉告诉侦探们，在她去的第二天，她走到屋外的垃圾桶里，发现里面有一条弄脏的床单。这似乎是在萨瓦尔、克里斯蒂安和第三个男人将尸体从公寓移走后被扔在那里的。在接下来的几周里，侦探们继续就古德蒙杜尔·埃纳尔松的失踪盘问埃拉。
She remained in Seedermulli Prison in solitary confinement. Saevar was also questioned and verified Erla's version of events. He told detectives that the third man Erla hadn't recognised was his friend, Trigvi Leifson. Saevar told detectives that Gutmunder, Christian, Trigvi and himself had gone to Erla's house. There had been a physical altercation which resulted in Gutmunder's death. Saevar called his friend Albert Skaftersen to pick them up to dispose of Gutmunde's body under the pretense of having cannabis for him. Albert was arrested and confirmed that he had arrived on the night in question in his father's yellow Toyota. He recalled Saevar had asked him to open the boot of the vehicle.
她被关在赛达穆利监狱的单人牢房里。萨瓦尔也受到了讯问，并证实了埃拉的说法。他告诉侦探，埃拉没认出的第三个男人是他的朋友特里格维·莱夫松（Trigvi Leifson）。萨瓦尔告诉侦探，古德蒙杜尔、克里斯蒂安、特里格维和他自己去了埃拉家。那里发生了一场肢体冲突，导致古德蒙杜尔死亡。萨瓦尔打电话给他的朋友阿尔伯特·斯卡夫特森（Albert Skaftersen），以有大麻为借口，接他们去处理古德蒙杜尔的尸体。阿尔伯特被捕了，并证实他在案发当晚开着他父亲的黄色丰田车赶到了。他回忆说，萨瓦尔让他打开汽车的后备箱。
him to open the boot of the vehicle. Watching from the rearview mirror, he witnessed Saevar, Trigvi and Christian carry a large bag with the difficulty out of the front door. They pushed it into the boot, causing the car to rock a little. From there, they travelled to the lava fields outside of Habnerfjordur and dumped the large bag. Saevar confided to Albert on the drive back that it contained a body. He said that he and Christian had hacked the body into pieces to make it easier to dispose of. Christian, who was already serving a six-month sentence in another Icelandic prison for theft, was brought to Seyðamulli for questioning.
让他打开汽车的后备箱。从后视镜看着，他目睹了萨瓦尔、特里格维和克里斯蒂安费力地从前门抬出一个大包。他们把它塞进后备箱，导致汽车微微晃动。从那里，他们前往哈布纳菲厄泽郊外的熔岩原，丢弃了大包。萨瓦尔在回程的车上向阿尔伯特吐露里面装着一具尸体。他说他和克里斯蒂安把尸体剁成块，以便更容易处理。克里斯蒂安因盗窃罪已在另一所冰岛监狱服刑六个月，他被带到塞亚穆利接受讯问。
He also provided a statement confirming that he was at Erla's house on the night of Gudmundur's disappearance, and that a fight broke out between Tryggvi and Gudmundur, resulting in his death. Admitting that he was heavily intoxicated at the time, Christian could only recall fragments of the rest of the night. He did remember getting into Albert's yellow Toyota and going to the lava fields to dispose of the body. After Christian had been questioned at 1.42 am, he was driven to the lava fields in an attempt to jog his memory and show detectives where Guthmunder was buried. They returned to see the Muli prison at 3am, having failed to locate
他还提供了一份声明，确认他在古德蒙杜尔失踪当晚在埃拉家，特里格维和古德蒙杜尔之间爆发了一场争斗，导致后者死亡。克里斯蒂安承认当时自己喝得酩酊大醉，只能回忆起当晚其余时间的片段。他确实记得坐上阿尔伯特的黄色丰田车去熔岩原处理尸体。克里斯蒂安于凌晨 1.42 分接受讯问后，被驱车前往熔岩原，试图唤醒他的记忆并向侦探展示古德蒙杜尔被埋葬的地方。他们在凌晨 3 点返回穆利监狱，未能找到
Guthmunder's remains. Trigvi Leifson was an athletic man. He was kind and gentle, but also known to get into fights when drunk As the circumstances of Gudmundur Einarsson's death unravelled, he too was questioned in relation to his involvement He initially denied everything, but after weeks of solitary confinement, admitted that he had thought a lot about the case and was ready to talk to detectives. On January 9 1976, he admitted to his part in Gutmunder's death, although he didn't know the man personally, telling detectives, There was some disagreement, I'm sure, between Christian and the man with no name. It started by them cursing each other but ended in a fight. Then the man hit me and I think I hit him and he fell to the floor. Then I saw Saevar kick him in the head.
古德蒙杜尔的遗体。特里格维·莱夫松是一个身材健美的男子。他善良温和，但也以酒后好斗而闻名。随着古德蒙杜尔·埃纳尔松死亡真相的揭开，他也因涉案而遭到讯问。他起初否认了一切，但在经历了数周的单独监禁后，他承认自己对这起案件想了很多，已经准备好与侦探交谈了。1976 年 1 月 9 日，他承认了自己在古德蒙杜尔死亡事件中所扮演的角色，尽管他不认识这个人，他告诉侦探：“我敢肯定，克里斯蒂安和那个没有名字的男人之间有一些分歧。它始于他们互相诅咒，但以一场斗殴告终。然后那个人打了我，我想我打了那个他，他摔倒在地。然后我看到萨瓦尔踢他的头。”
Saevar, Christian, Albert and Trygve were held in custody. Erla, after it was determined she played no part in the murder of Gudmundur, was free to leave to await a court date for the money fraud case. Ten days after being arrested, she went to live with her mother, ecstatic to be reunited with her daughter. Although Erla was free from the confines of a jail cell, she continued to be visited regularly by investigators who came around for coffee and cigarettes to discuss the Guthmunde case with her. Over the time of her incarceration, these men had become Erla's confidants. She felt they were more like friends than detectives. She became particularly close to Detective Sigjobjörn Wither, who was young, helpful and sympathetic to Erla and her ordeal.
萨瓦尔、克里斯蒂安、阿尔伯特和特里格维被拘留。在确定埃拉没有参与谋杀古德蒙杜尔后，她获释离开，等待金钱诈骗案的法庭审理。被捕十天后，她去和母亲住在一起，欣喜若狂地与女儿团聚。尽管埃拉摆脱了牢狱之灾，但调查人员仍定期来找她喝咖啡、抽烟，并与她讨论古德蒙杜尔案。在她的监禁期间，这些男人成了埃拉的知己。她觉得他们与其说是侦探，不如说是朋友。她与年轻、乐于助人且对埃拉及其磨难抱有同情心的侦探西格约约本·威瑟（Sigjobjörn Wither）变得尤其亲密。
One day, Detective Wither asked Erla a question out of the blue. One day, Detective Veda asked Erla a question out of the blue. If she or Saevar knew anything about the disappearance of Geirfinnur Einarsson. She replied, maybe. Erla confided that she had been receiving threatening calls at her mother's house, warning her that she had said too much to detectives. When asked who she thought was making the calls, Erla suspected it may have been her half-brother, professional basketball player Einar Bothersen. She also believed that some of his friends were involved, including a man who ran a nightclub named Kluberen in Reykjavik. The man was Magnus Leopoldsen.
一天，威瑟侦探出其不意地问了埃拉一个问题。一天，韦达侦探突兀地问了埃拉一个问题。她或萨瓦尔是否知道关于盖尔芬纳·埃纳尔松失踪的任何事情。她回答说，也许吧。埃拉吐露，她一直在母亲家里接到威胁电话，警告她对侦探说得太多了。当被问及她认为是谁在打电话时，埃拉怀疑可能是她的同母异父兄弟、职业篮球运动员埃纳尔·博瑟森（Einar Bothersen）。她还认为他的几个朋友也参与其中，其中包括一个在雷克雅未克经营一家名为 Kluberen 的夜总会的男子。那个人是马格努斯·利奥波尔德森。
Erla was not particularly close to her half-brother Eina. Their relationship had soured after Erla began dating Saevar, a man Einar despised for his involvement in petty crimes. Following this, detectives questioned Saevar about Geirfinnur. He refused to comment initially, but provided a statement to police on January 22 1976. He admitted he had seen Geirfinnur on the night of his disappearance He had gone to the Keblavik docks with Kristjan, Erla and some other men to smuggle alcohol into Iceland One of the other men met Geirfinnur outside a cafe and brought him along and brought him along. Saevar then said he went for a drive and when he returned to pick up the men, it was immediately apparent that their smuggling operation had gone awry. Geirfinnur had fallen off the boat and drowned in freezing waters.
埃拉和她的同母异父兄弟埃纳尔并不是特别亲近。自从埃拉开始与萨瓦尔约会后，他们的关系就恶化了，埃纳尔因为萨瓦尔参与轻微犯罪而鄙视他。在此之后，侦探们就盖尔芬纳一事盘问了萨瓦尔。他起初拒绝置评，但于 1976 年 1 月 22 日向警方提供了一份声明。他承认他在盖尔芬纳失踪当晚见过他。他曾与克里斯蒂安、埃拉和其他一些人一起去凯夫拉维克码头走私酒精进冰岛。其中另一个人在咖啡馆外遇到了盖尔芬纳并把他带了过来，并把他带了过来。萨瓦尔随后说他去兜风了，当他回来接那些人时，很明显他们的走私行动搞砸了。盖尔芬纳从船上掉下来，在冰冷的水中溺水身亡。
Erla shared a similar story, however, she implicated Saevar further in Geirfinnur's death The police notes taken from Erla's interrogation read On the night of 19 November 1974, Erla and Saevar had been at Kluberen and they were not having much fun. They decided to leave and got into a blue Mercedes with two others, taking off without a planned destination. They headed out of Reykjavik. They drove past her home in Habnefjorda and on towards the airport at Keblavik. Saevar held onto her hand the whole time, even when she tried to release his grip. He spoke to the driver, she couldn't remember the exact conversation. They were talking about killing someone by taking him out to sea, pretending they were going to get something.
埃拉分享了一个类似的故事，然而，她将萨瓦尔更深地牵连进盖尔芬纳的死中。从埃拉审讯中摘录的警方记录写道：1974 年 11 月 19 日晚，埃拉和萨瓦尔在 Kluberen，他们玩得并不开心。他们决定离开，和另外两个人坐上一辆蓝色奔驰，在没有计划目的地的情况下出发了。他们驶出了雷克雅未克。他们开车经过她在哈布纳菲厄泽的家，向凯夫拉维克机场驶去。萨瓦尔一路上一直抓着她的手，即使她试图挣脱。他跟司机说话，她记不清具体的对话了。他们在谈论通过把某人带到海里、假装要去拿什么东西来杀掉他。
It was a last resort. They had tried to offer this man money, but he wouldn't listen. They would have to make him disappear. They were on a mission to murder. When they reached Kevlovik, they stopped by the foreshore. It was a spooky place at night, littered with battered trawlers propped up on blocks waiting to be repaired before being thrust back into the sea. When they got out of the car, Erla saw the face of the driver who had been speaking to Saevar. It was Magnus Leopoldsen from Klubberen. There were other men there. Geirfinnur had promised the men he could get hold of smuggled alcohol being dropped from a boat out at sea.
这是万不得已的办法。他们曾试图给这个人钱，但他不听。他们不得不让他人间蒸发。他们肩负着谋杀的任务。当他们到达凯夫拉维克时，他们在前滩停了下来。这是一个夜里阴森恐怖的地方，到处都是破烂不堪的拖网渔船，靠在木块上等待修复，然后再被推回海里。当他们下车时，埃拉看到了和萨瓦尔说话的那个司机的脸。那是来自 Klubberen 的马格努斯·利奥波尔德森。那里还有其他人。盖尔芬纳曾向这些人保证，他能弄到从海上一艘船上空投的走私酒。
Erla recognised her half-brother Einar and Saevar's friend and familiar partner in crime, Christian Vithersen. Geirfinnur was talking to to Saiba and Magnus when a fight broke out. The others were preoccupied and didn't see her inching away, and then she ran. She wanted to get away and hide. She found an abandoned house which was either still being built or used for storage. She hid there in a corner. She couldn't remember for exactly how long. As she waited, she felt so bad that she threw up. On January 23, Christiane also confessed to being at Keblevik that night and seeing Saevar, Erla and her half-brother Einar there.
埃拉认出了她的同母异父兄弟埃纳尔、萨瓦尔的朋友兼熟悉的犯罪同伙克里斯蒂安·维瑟森。盖尔芬纳正和萨巴以及马格努斯说话，这时爆发了一场争斗。其他人全神贯注，没有看到她慢慢挪开，然后她跑了。她想逃跑并躲藏起来。她发现了一座废弃的房子，要么还在建设中，要么用作仓库。她躲在角落里。她记不清具体有多久了。在她等待的时候，她感觉难受得吐了。1 月 23 日，克里斯蒂安也供认当晚在凯夫拉维克，并看到萨瓦尔、埃拉和她的同母异父兄弟埃纳尔在那里。
However, being under the influence of drugs for the latter part of 1974, Christiane was hazy about the details. Three days later, Eina and Magnus were arrested, as was Magnus' nightclub co-owner Sigur Björn Eriksson and Valdemar Olsson, the brother of one of Erla's friends The arrest of these four men sent shockwaves throughout Iceland They gained notoriety as the Kluberuran Four from the name of the nightclub owned by Magnus and Sigjubjörn. Unlike Saevar and his friends who were involved in petty crimes, these men were well-respected members of the community. Rumours circulated that these men were part of an organised crime syndicate and were being protected from those in positions of power, including the Minister for Justice Despite long stints in solitary confinement and hours of questioning, the Kluberan Four continued to protest their innocence
然而，由于在1974年下半年受到药物影响，克里斯蒂安妮对细节记不太清。三天后，埃娜和马格努斯被捕，马格努斯的夜总会合伙人西古尔·比约恩·埃里克松以及埃拉朋友的兄弟瓦尔德马尔·奥尔松也一同被捕。这四名男子的被捕在整个冰岛引发了强烈震动。他们因马格努斯和西古尔比亚恩拥有的夜总会名称而被称为“克卢贝鲁兰四人组”。与卷入轻微犯罪的塞瓦尔及其朋友不同，这些人是社区中备受尊敬的成员。有传言称这些人是有组织犯罪集团的一部分，并受到权势人物（包括司法部长）的保护。尽管经历长时间的单独监禁和数小时的审讯，克卢贝鲁兰四人组仍然坚称自己无辜。
In an attempt to calm the public, police held a press conference. The Kluber and Four had been in custody for two months. The investigation team felt pressured to reassure the public that they were doing what they could to solve the case. With over a year that had passed since Geirfinnur's disappearance, detectives felt that it wouldn't be long before the truth came out. Basketball player Einar Bothlason was sitting in his prison cell at Seethermoorley, where he had been incarcerated for the last three months. where he had been incarcerated for the last three months. He maintained his innocence, certain that his half-sister, Erla, had implicated him because of his dislike of Saevar.
为了平息公众情绪，警方举行了一场新闻发布会。克卢贝鲁兰四人组已被关押两个月。调查组感到有压力向公众保证他们正在尽一切努力破案。距离盖尔芬努尔失踪已经过去了一年多，侦探们觉得真相大白不久了。篮球运动员埃纳尔·博特拉松正坐在锡瑟莫利监狱的牢房里，他在那里已被关押了三个月。他坚信自己的同母异父姐姐埃拉因为不喜欢塞瓦尔而诬陷了他。
As extra punishment by the prison guards, Einar had been moved into the smallest cell available. It was barely high enough to contain his tall frame His limbs hung over the hard rubber mattress that lined the concrete bed Einar had a revelation The night of Geirfinnur's disappearance suddenly came to him He had been watching television at home with his family. There was a documentary about Scottish men participating in the Highland Games. He informed the investigators about his memories of the program,
作为狱警的额外惩罚，埃纳尔被转移到了能找到的最小牢房里。牢房几乎装不下他高大的身材，他的四肢悬挂在水泥床上的硬橡胶床垫上。埃纳尔顿悟了。盖尔芬努尔失踪的那天晚上突然浮现在他的脑海里。那天他正和家人在家看电视。节目是一部关于苏格兰人参加高地运动会的纪录片。他将自己对这个节目的记忆告知了调查人员，
who in turn took him to the television station to review the tapes. The video was paused and Einer explained what happened next. He also remembered earlier in the night that he had been fundraising for his basketball team. Other team members confirmed his alibi, as did a babysitter hired to look after Eina's children that night. Upon investigating the other alibis, Magnus Leopoldsen also had someone to vouch for his whereabouts. An employee at Kluberen's cloakroom kept a detailed log on the comings and goings of various staff members. On the night of Geirfinna's disappearance, she documented that Magnus had been at the club from early evening until midnight, meaning he couldn't have been at the Keblavik docks at the time specified by Erla and Saevar. The Kluberan Four were innocent.
调查人员随后带他去电视台查阅录像带。视频暂停了，埃纳尔解释了接下来发生的事情。他还记起当晚早些时候他一直在为自己的篮球队筹款。其他队员证实了他的不在场证明，当晚受雇照顾埃娜孩子的保姆也证实了这一点。在调查其他不在场证明时，马格努斯·利奥波尔德森也有人证明他的行踪。克卢贝伦衣帽间的一名员工详细记录了各种员工的出入情况。在盖尔芬娜失踪的那晚，她记录道马格努斯从傍晚一直待到午夜，这意味着在埃拉和塞瓦尔指定的时间，他不可能在凯夫拉维克码头。克卢贝鲁兰四人组是无辜的。
were innocent. After four months in custody, Magnus Leopoldsen, Einar Bothersen, Sigurdbjörn Eriksson and Valdemar Olsen were released from Seedermuhle prison. Aside from the statements made by Erla, Saevar and Kristjan, there was no evidence to connect them to the murder of Geirfinnur Einarsson. there was no evidence to connect them to the murder of Geir Finner-Einerson. The men were placed under police surveillance and warned not to speak to the media about the case. Embarrassed, Detective zeroed in on Erla, certain she had implicated the Kluberan IV as a ruse to take the heat off herself. Now under more pressure than ever to solve the cases and to recover from the public shame of arresting and holding four prominent Icelandic citizens, it was decided that outside help would be enlisted
是无辜的。在被关押四个月后，马格努斯·利奥波尔德森、埃纳尔·博特尔森、西古尔德比约恩·埃里克松和瓦尔德马尔·奥尔森从锡德穆勒监狱获释。除了埃拉、塞瓦尔和克里斯蒂安的供词外，没有证据将他们与盖尔芬努尔·埃纳尔松的谋杀案联系起来。这些人受到警方监视，并被警告不要就此案向媒体发言。感到尴尬的侦探将矛头指向埃拉，确信她牵连克卢贝鲁兰四人组是为了转移自己身上的压力。现在，为了破案并挽回逮捕和拘留四名冰岛知名公民所带来的公众羞辱，各方决定寻求外部援助，
to solve the Gudmundur and Geirfinna disappearances. In May 1976, the Minister of Justice hired prominent detective Karl Schutz from Germany to assist. He assembled a team and in brusque German told the public through a translator that he would solve the crimes. Schutz poured over the case and re-interviewed Saevar, Christian and Trygve, who were still in custody. Albert, accused of driving
以侦破古德门杜尔和盖尔芬娜失踪案。1976年5月，司法部长聘请了德国知名侦探卡尔·舒茨前来协助。他组建了一个团队，并以生硬的德语通过翻译向公众表示他将破获这些罪行。舒茨仔细研究了案卷，并重新讯问了仍在押的塞瓦尔、克里斯蒂安和特里格维。被指控驾驶黄色丰田汽车将古德门杜尔的尸体运去掩埋的阿尔伯特已被释放。5月3日，埃拉·博特勒多蒂尔因在牵连克卢贝鲁兰四人组一事上作伪证而被捕。她情绪低落，侦探们对她的心理健康感到担忧。
Gutmunder's body for burial in the yellow Toyota, had been released. On May 3, Erla Bothlerdotter was arrested for perjury in implicating the Kluberin Four. She was morose and detectives were concerned for her mental health.
埃拉与侦探卡尔·舒茨坐在一起。在口译员的帮助下，他讯问她为什么要将这些人指认为嫌疑人。最终，埃拉敞开了心扉。她向侦探做出的供词解释了她沮丧的状态。埃拉承认自己用步枪在凯夫拉维克码头亲手枪杀了盖尔芬娜。根据《雷克雅未克供词》一书，警方记录写道：在昏暗的光线中，塞瓦尔递给她一个沉重的东西。那是一支步枪，尽管她说不清它具体长什么样。他教她如何握枪，但这不是为了吓唬人。他们打算使用它。盖亚菲娜被带了过来，她离他那么近，以至于能看到他的脸，当他意识到即将发生什么时，脸上充满了恐惧和惊恐。他们已经想出了解决这个烦人、无理取闹的男人的办法。埃拉扣动扳机时闭上了眼睛。当子弹从枪管飞入盖尔芬努尔的身体时，步枪在她手中猛烈震动。塞瓦尔立即从她手中拿过步枪，他们处理了倒在地上奄奄一息的男人，他的鲜血染红了雪地。直到事后埃拉才惊慌失措，在混乱中她得以溜走，藏在附近一座荒废的房子里过夜。第二天她回家时，塞瓦尔很生气。他想知道她一整夜都在哪。他再也没有提过盖亚·菲娜，也拒绝谈论那个夜晚。他们要把这件事从脑海中抹去，这是一个他们将永远保守的秘密。他们假装这一切从未发生过。
Erla sat with Detective Karl Schutz. Through the help of an interpreter, he interrogated her as to why she had named them as suspects. Eventually, Erla opened up. The confession she gave to detectives explained her dejected state. Erla confessed to shooting Geirfinner herself at the Keblavik docks with a rifle. From the book The Reykjavik Confessions, the police notes read, In the murky light, Saevar handed her something heavy. It was a rifle, although she couldn't say exactly what it looked like. He showed her how to hold it, but it wasn't there as a scare tactic. They intended to use it. Gayafina was brought over and she had been so
这份供词与西弗斯的说法相矛盾，后者现在称他用木板击打盖奥菲娜的头部将其杀死。克里斯蒂安的供述则回忆说他被淹死在大海里。经查明，克里斯蒂安就是打电话把盖亚菲娜叫到咖啡馆的那个人。侦探们对行凶者不断改变的供词感到恼火。在绝望中，他们安排埃拉、塞瓦尔和克里斯蒂安一起接受讯问，以查明实际发生了什么。经过数小时的讯问，最终达成了一份供词并签字画押。塞瓦尔和克里斯蒂安对盖亚菲娜的死负有责任，而埃拉只是一个无辜的旁观者。
close to him she could see his face, etched with fear and horror as he realised what was about to happen to him. They had come up with a solution for this annoying, unreasonable man. Erla closed her eyes as she pulled the trigger. The rifle jolted in her hands as the bullet flew from the barrel into Geirfinnur's body. Saevar immediately took the rifle from her as they dealt with the man dying on the ground in front of them, his blood staining the snow. It was only after the fact that Erla panicked and in the confusion she was able to sneak away and hide in a deserted house close by, where she spent the night. by where she spent the night. When she returned home the next day, Saevar was angry. He wanted to know where she had been all night. He never mentioned Gaea Finna again and refused to talk about that night. They would banish it from their minds, a secret they would keep for themselves. They would pretend it never happened.
警方同意她可能只是想通过承担罪责来保护其他人。搜寻盖尔芬努尔尸体的工作随即展开。埃拉向侦探们指出了她认为塞瓦尔和克里斯蒂安埋葬他的地方。拉索拉，也被称为红山，位于雷克雅未克郊区，是一片广袤、多石的景观，荒凉的地面上隆起一堆堆红土。正是在这片区域，塞瓦尔和克里斯蒂安承认在放火焚烧盖尔芬努尔的尸体并将其倾倒在浅坑后，将其埋葬于此。该区域被彻底发掘，但并未找到盖尔芬努尔。当被问及他的尸体是如何被运送到如此偏僻的地方时，三人均说出了32岁的古德容·斯卡普耶特松的名字。
This confession contradicted Sivers, who now said that he had killed Geofina by hitting him on the head with a wooden plank. Christian's account recalled he had drowned in the ocean. It was determined that Christian had been the man who had called Gayafina to the cafe. Detectives were irritated at the perpetrator's ever-changing confessions. In desperation, they organised for Erla, Saevar and Christian to be interviewed together to find out what had actually happened. After hours of questioning, a final confession was agreed upon and signed. Saevar and Christian were responsible for Gayafina's death, while Erla was an innocent bystander.
他开车将他们从凯夫拉维克码头送到红山。古德容是一名退伍学校教师，也是塞瓦尔的朋友，随即被捕。鉴于他是一位备受尊敬的学校教师，且年龄比同案犯大，他的供词被认为最具有可信度。古德容没有不在场证明，因为他不记得盖尔芬努尔失踪当晚自己做了什么。他最初否认有任何卷入，但在被拘留两周后向卡尔·舒茨坦白。除了担任将盖尔芬努尔尸体运往红山的汽车司机外，古德容还承认与塞瓦尔和克里斯蒂安一起将盖尔芬努尔殴打致死。根据纪录片《凭空消失》，古德容说：
Police agreed she was likely trying to protect the others by taking responsibility for the crime. A search commenced for Geirfinnur's body. Erla showed detectives where she believed Saevar and Christian buried him. Rathola, also known as the Red Hills, on the outskirts of Reykjavik, was a vast, rocky landscape where mounds of red dirt rose up from the barren ground. It was in this area that Saevar and Christian confessed to burying Geirfinnur after setting his body alight and then dumping it in a shallow grave. The area was excavated thoroughly, but Geirfinnur wasn't found. When asked how his body was transported to such an isolated location, all three named 32-year-old Gutjohn Skarp-Jethenson.
我们三人与盖奥菲娜发生冲突，导致了他的死亡。我不记得尸体被放进车里，但在返回雷克雅未克的路上，我记得我很伤心，因为我是谋杀案的共犯。1977年1月23日，卡尔·舒茨举行新闻发布会，宣布所有涉嫌谋杀古德门杜尔和盖尔芬纳-埃纳尔松的嫌疑人都已被拘留。他解释说，尽管他们没有找到任何一具尸体，但供词构成了95%的证据，并且合情合理。舒茨概述了埃拉、塞瓦尔、特里格维、克里斯蒂安和古德容为使调查复杂化、将罪责从自己身上转移开而采取的种种企图。
He drove them 50 kilometres from the Keblavik docks to the Red Hills. Gutjohn, a former schoolteacher and friend of Saevar's, was placed under arrest. Given that he was a well-regarded schoolteacher and older than his counterparts, his confession was given the most credibility Guthion had no alibi as he was not able to remember what he had done the night of Geirfinnur's disappearance Initially denying any involvement, he confessed to Karl Schutz two weeks after being taken into custody. As well as being the driver of the car that took Geirfinnur's body to the Red Hills, Guthion also admitted to beating Geirfinnur to death with Saevar and Christian. From the documentary Out of Thin Air, Guthion said
他在发布会结束时说：“正如我们刑事调查人员常说的那样，这个案子毋庸置疑。可以肯定地说这是一个板上钉钉的案子。”他认为塞瓦尔是整个行动背后兼具街头智慧的团伙头目，古德容是智囊，克里斯蒂安则是打手。他把特里格维和阿尔伯特描绘成只是容易受另外三人支配的瘾君子，埃拉也是如此，为了得到塞瓦尔的认可，她什么都愿意做。
The three of us fought with Geofina, that resulted in his death I don't remember the body being put into the car, but on the way back to Reykjavik, I remember I was sad that I was an accomplice to murder. On January 23 1977, Karl Schutz held a press conference to announce that all suspects had been detained for the murders of Gutmunder and Geirfinner-Einerson. He explained that even though they had not located either body, the confessions were 95% of the evidence and were plausible. Schutz outlined the attempts that Erler, Saevar, Trigvi, Christian and Guthion had made to complicate the investigation to shift the focus of guilt off themselves.
冰岛首相奥拉维尔·约翰内松赞扬了侦探卡尔·舒茨的工作。他对公众说：“噩梦已经结束。”审判于1977年10月3日开始。根据冰岛的纠问式诉讼制度，该案已经由地方法官审理过。他们作出了有罪判决。随后，案件提交至最高法院，由五名法官代替陪审团来决定被告的命运。在国家检察官进行了15个半小时的陈述后，塞瓦尔·西谢尔斯基走上了证人席。
He concluded the conference by saying, As we criminal investigators like to say, this case is beyond reasonable doubt. It's safe to assume it's an open and shut case. He opined that Saevar was the ringleader with the street smarts behind the operation, Gutjohn was the brains and Christian was the brawn. He painted Trigvi and Albert as simply stoners who were easily led by the other three, as was Erla, who would do anything for Saevar's approval. for Saevar's approval.
身穿喇叭裤的天鹅绒西装、戴着飞行员眼镜、长发披肩，消瘦憔悴的塞瓦尔坚称自己无辜。他恳求撤回自己和同案被告的供词。克里斯蒂安在前排身体前倾，目光在法庭四处游移。埃拉穿着围裙裙，头发别在一侧，看起来像个孩子般若有所思，头部靠在手上。审判持续了五天。仅仅十周多后，这群人得知了他们的命运。所有人均被判有罪。由于在父亲的黄色丰田车里运送古德门杜尔尸体所起的作用，阿尔伯特·斯卡夫特森被判处15个月监禁。尽管被判无罪，没有参与古德门杜尔和盖尔芬纳的谋杀案，
The Icelandic Prime Minister, Oliver Johannesson, praised Detective Karl Schütze's work. He told the public, The nightmare is over. The murder trial began on October 3 1977. Under the Icelandic system, an inquisitorial system, the case had already been heard by district judges. They had returned a guilty verdict. From there, the case went to the Supreme Court, where instead of a jury, five judges were left to decide the defendant's fate. After 15 and a half hours of testimony from the state prosecutor, Saevar Ciesielski took the stand. Dressed in a velvet
但埃拉·博特勒多蒂尔因涉嫌金钱诈骗案侵占财产以及因牵连克卢贝鲁兰四人组犯下他们未曾参与的罪行而作伪证，被判处三年监禁。古德容·斯卡普耶特松因参与杀害盖尔芬努尔并运送尸体掩埋被判处12年监禁。特里格维·莱夫松因杀害古德门杜尔被判处16年监禁，塞瓦尔·切尔斯基和克里斯蒂安·维杜尔松均因杀害古德门杜尔和盖尔芬努尔被判处无期徒刑。这使得塞瓦尔和克里斯蒂安成为冰岛100多年来首批被判定犯有双重谋杀罪的人。
suit with flared pants, abiator glasses, and his long hair loose, the thin and gaunt Saevar professed his innocence. He pleaded for his statements and those of his co-accused to be retracted. Christian sat forward in the front row, eyes darting around the courtroom. Erla, wearing a pinafore with her hair pinned to the side, looked childlike and contemplative, her head resting on her hand. The trial lasted five days. Just over ten weeks later, the group learned their fate. All were found guilty. For his role in transporting the body of Guthmunder in his father's yellow Toyota, Albert Skaftersen was sentenced to 15 months prison. Although found innocent of any
宣读判决时，没有一名嫌疑人在法庭现场。他们是在第二天清晨的牢房里阅读报纸或由狱警告知才得知审判结果的。他们一个接一个地被运送到冰岛各地的不同监狱服刑，抛下了锡瑟莫利监狱的禁闭。冰岛人欢欣鼓舞，因为杀害他们同胞的凶手终于被赶出了街道。问题是，他们全都是无辜的。1975年12月13日，埃拉·博勒多蒂尔因涉嫌金钱诈骗案被捕后，第一次被押送进入锡瑟莫利监狱时感到十分紧张。在承认诈骗后，埃拉起身准备离开。一名调查人员随后在她面前挥舞着一张照片。那是古德门杜尔·埃纳尔松的照片。她几年前在一个派对上见过他。
involvement in the murders of Guthmunder and Geirfinner, Erla Botlerdotter was sentenced to three years for embezzlement in the money scam and perjury for implicating the Kluberan IV in a crime they didn't commit. Gudjon Skarpjæðinsson was sentenced to 12 years for his part in the death of Geirfinnur and transporting the body for burial. Tryggvi Leifsson was sentenced to 16 years for killing Gudmundur and Saevar Tjerskjölski and Kristjan Vidursson were both sentenced to life in prison for killing Gudmundur and Geirfinnur This made Saevar and Kristjan the first people in Iceland to be convicted of a double murder in more than 100 years
侦探问她他失踪的那天晚上她在哪里。埃拉记起了1974年1月27日那个夜晚。她和朋友去参加了一个派对，急于离开。后来，她躺在床上。外面暴风雪肆虐，狂风猛烈抽打着建筑，发出嘎吱嘎吱的响声。埃拉向讯问的侦探讲述了她当晚做的一个噩梦。梦开始于窗外传来的声音。他们用压低的声音讨论埃拉是否醒着。埃拉吓坏了。她起身查看是谁，看到塞瓦尔、
Iceland to be convicted of a double murder in more than 100 years. None of the suspects were present in court when the verdicts were read. They learned of their outcome as they read the newspaper in their cells the following morning or being told by prison guards. One by one they were shipped off to various prisons around Iceland to serve their sentences, leaving the confines of Seathamully Prison behind. Icelanders rejoiced that those responsible for the deaths of two of their own were off the streets. Problem was, they were all innocent. Erla Bolledotter was nervous as she was escorted into Seethamuli Prison for the first time on December 13 1975 after being arrested for the money fraud scam. After confessing to the fraud, Erla stood up to leave. An investigator then waved a photo in front of her. It was of Gudmundur Einarsson. She met him at a party years ago.
克里斯蒂安和一个她不认识的人。就在那时她醒了。侦探们打断了她，提醒她塞瓦尔是个小偷，并利用她担心他对自己不忠的心理。在向调查人员一遍又一遍地讲述她的噩梦后，首席侦探向前探过身去。埃拉后来在纪录片《凭空消失》中谈到此事。据埃拉回忆，他说：“那天晚上在那间公寓里发生了一件可怕的事情。你目睹了它，但由于它给你带来的创伤，你记不起来了。所以我们现在要做的是把你送回牢房，这样你就可以尽量多地回忆，然后我们再谈谈。”他们通知埃拉第二天早上将恢复讯问。埃拉躺在牢房里辗转难眠，试图回忆发生了什么。
The detective asked her where she had been the night he disappeared. Erla remembered that night of January 27 1974. She had been at a party with a friend and desperate to leave. Later, she lay in bed. The snowstorm roared on outside as wild winds lashed the building, making the walls creak. Erla told the interviewing detective about a nightmare she had that night. It began with voices outside of her window. In hushed tones, they discussed whether Erla was awake or not. Erla was terrified. Erla was awake or not. Erla was terrified. She got up to check who it was and saw Saevar,
她为塞瓦尔的背叛感到难过，因为他把金钱诈骗案的责任全推到她一个人头上，她想起了他曾对她不忠的种种时刻。这一夜过去，埃拉开始觉得或许塞瓦尔真的卷入了古德门杜尔的失踪和死亡。她搜寻记忆中到底发生了什么。她的脑海里充满了各种画面，她开始怀疑自己的噩梦是否真实。她更加努力地回想。现在，埃拉记起自己曾站在储藏室门口，看到那些男人拿着一个袋子。它看起来像是一具尸体的形状。第二天早上她把这些告诉了调查人员。他们鼓励她，称赞她是多么勇敢
Christian, and someone she didn't know. It was then that she woke up. The detectives interjected, reminding her that Saevar was a petty thief and played on her worry that he was unfaithful to her. After telling the investigators about her nightmare over and over, the lead detective leant forward. Erla later spoke on the documentary out of thin air. According to Erla, he said, Something terrible happened that night in that apartment. You witnessed it, and you cannot recall it because of the trauma it caused you. So what we're going to do now is get you back to your cell so you can try and remember as much as you can, and then we'll talk about it some more." They advised Erla they would resume questioning the next morning Erla lay awake in her cell, trying to remember what had happened
She was saddened by Saevar's betrayal implicating her solely in the money scam and she thought of the times he had been unfaithful to her. Over the night, Erla came to think that perhaps Saevar had been involved in Gudmundur's disappearance and death. She searched her memory as to what had happened. Her head was full of images, and she came to question whether her nightmare was real. She thought harder. Now, Erla remembered being at the door to the storage room and seeing the men with a bag It looked like it was in the shape of a body She told detectives this the following morning They encouraged her, telling her how brave she was
她为塞瓦尔的背叛感到难过，因为他把金钱诈骗案的责任全推到她一个人头上，她想起了他曾对她不忠的种种时刻。这一夜过去，埃拉开始觉得或许塞瓦尔真的卷入了古德门杜尔的失踪和死亡。她搜寻记忆中到底发生了什么。她的脑海里充满了各种画面，她开始怀疑自己的噩梦是否真实。她更加努力地回想。现在，埃拉记起自己曾站在储藏室门口，看到那些男人拿着一个袋子。它看起来像是一具尸体的形状。第二天早上她把这些告诉了调查人员。他们鼓励她，称赞她是多么勇敢
When she failed to remember something, the investigators presented her with theories. Could Gutmunder have been in a fight in the cottage? Could Saevar have taken his body somewhere? The more she thought about it, the more Erla could see a picture in her mind. She told detectives she had found a sheet in the bin the next day, but was too embarrassed to admit that she had thrown it out after soiling herself during the night Instead, Erla became evasive and told them that she didn't know how her sheet had come to be discarded in the trash Detectives mistook her evasiveness for guilt and interrogated her for hours about it. She admitted it may have contained Gudmundur's body. When she signed the confession and was let out of prison,
当她记不清某些事情时，调查人员会向她提出各种假设。古德芒德尔是不是在小屋里打过架？萨瓦尔是不是把他的尸体带到了别处？埃尔拉越想，脑海中的画面就越清晰。她告诉侦探，第二天她在垃圾桶里发现了一张床单，但她觉得难堪，不敢承认那是自己夜里尿床后扔掉的。相反，埃尔拉变得闪烁其词，告诉他们她不知道自己的床单是怎么被扔进垃圾桶的。侦探们把她的闪烁其词误认为是心虚，并为此对她进行了数小时的审讯。她承认床单里可能包裹着古德芒德尔的尸体。当她签署了供词并被释放出狱时，
Erla was relieved. She thought it was all over. thought it was all over. Days later, detectives phoned Erla to say that Saevar had confessed to killing Gudmundur with Christian and Trygve. He admitted to cutting Gudmundur's body into pieces, placing it into a linen bag and then driving it away with Albert to dispose of it. then driving it away with Albert to dispose of it. Erla was horrified, but reassured. Now that Saevar had confessed, her memories must have been correct. Erla couldn't believe that she didn't recall the dismemberment of Gudmundur's body, but Saevar and Christian had confirmed she was present, so she knew she must have witnessed it.
埃尔拉如释重负。她以为这一切都结束了。她以为这一切都结束了。几天后，侦探打电话给埃尔拉，称萨瓦尔已经承认与克里斯蒂安和特里格维一起杀害了古德芒德尔。他承认将古德芒德尔的尸体分尸，装进一个亚麻袋里，然后开车和阿尔伯特一起去抛尸。然后开车和阿尔伯特一起去抛尸。埃尔拉感到惊恐，但又感到一丝宽慰。既然萨瓦尔已经招供，那她的记忆一定没出错。埃尔拉简直不敢相信自己竟然记不起古德芒德尔被分尸的经过，但萨瓦尔和克里斯蒂安都证实她在场，所以她知道自己当时一定目睹了这一切。
Erla concluded that she couldn't trust her own memories. Meanwhile, Saevar, Christian and Trygve were in solitary confinement at Seedhamuli Prison. Weeks of hour-long interrogations, many without their lawyers present, had worn them down. They were drugged four times a day with various sedatives and left to sit alone, reflecting on what had happened. When Siver heard that Erla had implicated him in the murder of Guthmunder, he lay on his thin mattress racking his brain as to what had happened. lay on his thin mattress wracking his brain as to what had happened. When he really concentrated, he thought that maybe Albert had driven the car to dispose of Guthmunder's body and perhaps Gutheon had driven the car after the murder of Geirfinnur. After constant interrogating, Saevar gave the men up, desperate for the questioning to end.
埃尔拉得出结论，她再也无法相信自己的记忆了。与此同时，萨瓦尔、克里斯蒂安和特里格维被关押在希德哈穆利监狱的单人牢房里。长达数周、每次长达一小时的审讯（其中许多审讯没有律师在场）彻底摧毁了他们的意志。他们每天被注射四次各种镇静剂，然后被独自留在牢房里，反思发生的事情。当萨瓦尔听说埃尔拉将他卷入谋杀古德芒德尔的案件时，他躺在薄薄的床垫上，绞尽脑汁地回想究竟发生了什么。躺在薄薄的床垫上，绞尽脑汁地回想究竟发生了什么。当他真正集中精神时，他觉得也许是阿尔伯特开车去抛弃古德芒德尔的尸体，也许古德容在谋杀盖尔芬纳之后开过车。在不断的审讯下，为了结束这一切，萨瓦尔最终把其他人供了出去。
The detectives placed a typed confession in front of Saevar, Christian, Trigvi, Albert and Guthion. All they had to do was sign it and the interrogations and solitary confinement would be over. Drugged and confused, they all signed on the dotted line. In an early prison diary entry, Guthion wrote, The detective wants me to get used to the thought of being a murderer. If they think I am going to confess to Cyber and Erla's stories, then they are wrong. After a few weeks of solitary confinement and in a vulnerable state, Guthion wrote the following entry. You get tired and you don't know if you are dreaming or remembering things. The same
侦探们把一份打印好的供词放在萨瓦尔、克里斯蒂安、特里格维、阿尔伯特和古德容面前。他们要做的就是在上面签字，这样审讯和单人禁闭就会结束。在药物作用和意识模糊的情况下，他们在虚线上签了字。在早期的监狱日记中，古德容写道：“侦探想让我习惯自己是一个杀人犯的想法。如果他们以为我会承认赛博和埃尔拉的故事，那他们就大错特错了。”经过几周的单独监禁，处于脆弱状态的古德容写下了以下日记。你会感到疲惫，分不清自己是在做梦还是在回忆。同样的问题
questions over and over. I get completely confused. It came like clips of a movie into your mind. In the end, you feel like you have been there, like that this has really happened. Erla, Albert, Guthion, Trigvi, Christian and Saevar were all eventually released from prison after serving their required sentences. On August 9 1981, in what she later called the happiest day of her life, Erla was met on release by her and Saevar's five-year-old daughter holding a bouquet of flowers. Upon his release, Guthionón moved to Denmark to study theology When he returned to Iceland, he married and became a priest His notoriety had him sometimes snubbed by members of the Icelandic community, but over time he became accepted
一遍又一遍。我被彻底搞糊涂了。那些画面像电影片段一样浮现在脑海中。最后，你会觉得自己仿佛亲历过这一切，这一切就好像真的发生过一样。埃尔拉、阿尔伯特、古德容、特里格维、克里斯蒂安和萨瓦尔在服完规定的刑期后，最终都获释出狱。1981年8月9日，在埃尔拉后来被称为她一生中最快乐的日子里，她出狱时，她和萨瓦尔五岁的女儿手捧一束鲜花来迎接她。古德容出狱后搬到了丹麦学习神学。当他回到冰岛时，他结婚并成为了一名牧师。他的名气有时让他受到冰岛社区成员的冷落，但随着时间的推移，他逐渐被人们接受。
Christian found work in manual labour, but returned to prison for five years after physically assaulting his wife Albert found work as a carpenter, married and had children, completing charity work in his spare time Trigvy also found work as a decorator Of all six, Saevar struggled the most with life after prison. Released in 1984, Saevar married and had two sons. He struggled to find work, and everywhere he went people whispered and pointed to him as he walked past. He could go nowhere without being heckled. Saevar also suffered from nightmares reliving his time in prison. In 1993, Saevar and his family moved to Colorado in the USA for a
克里斯蒂安找到了一份体力活，但因对妻子实施家庭暴力而再次入狱五年。阿尔伯特找到了一份木匠的工作，结婚生子，并在业余时间做慈善工作。特里格维也找到了一份装饰工的工作。在这六个人中，萨瓦尔对出狱后的生活感到最艰难。萨瓦尔于1984年出狱，结婚并育有两个儿子。他很难找到工作，无论走到哪里，人们都在他身后窃窃私语，对他指指点点。他走到哪里都会受到辱骂。萨瓦尔还饱受噩梦折磨，不断重温在监狱里的时光。1993年，萨瓦尔和家人搬到了美国科罗拉多州，以求
fresh start. But Saevar could not stop thinking about clearing his name and the need to be found innocent by his Icelandic community consumed him. They returned to Iceland a year later. Prior to being incarcerated, Saevar did not drink alcohol, but on release he used it as a coping mechanism. It wasn't long before Saevar became an alcoholic. It wasn't long before Saevar became an alcoholic. He often met with Erla and they would talk about what had gone wrong that led them to make the accusations and confessions. However, Saevar was resentful of Erla for implicating him in the murders and there was a rift in their relationship that could not be repaired. Saevar hired a lawyer who pored over the case resources looking for evidence that Saevar was innocent. He was shocked by the police notes in the case
重新开始。但萨瓦尔无法停止洗清自己罪名的想法，冰岛社区需要还他清白的渴望折磨着他。一年后他们回到了冰岛。在入狱前，萨瓦尔不喝酒，但出狱后，他将酒精作为一种应对机制。没过多久，萨瓦尔就成了酒鬼。没过多久，萨瓦尔就成了酒鬼。他经常与埃尔拉见面，讨论究竟是什么环节出了问题，导致他们做出了指控和供认。然而，萨瓦尔对埃尔拉将他牵连进谋杀案一事心存怨恨，两人的关系出现了无法修复的裂痕。萨瓦尔雇了一名律师，仔细查阅案件资料，寻找萨瓦尔无罪的证据。他被警察在案卷中的记录震惊了，
and how heavily they had relied on confessions from the six when there were no bodies or evidence to link them to the crimes. On February 21 1997, Saevar appealed to the Supreme Court to have the case reopened. The judges ruled that there was not enough evidence to reopen the case, however they conceded that Saevar was badly mistreated in prison. He appealed another two times to have his name cleared over the following years, with no success. The process was taking its toll heavily on Saevar, who drank to excess, became bankrupt, separated from his wife and ended up on the streets. He had a following of people who believed in his innocence and many of the Icelandic community had changed their minds about him. Saevar Csácsalski died in July 2011 at the age of 56.
在既没有尸体也没有证据将他们与罪行联系起来的情况下，他们竟然如此严重地依赖这六人的供词。1997年2月21日，萨瓦尔向最高法院上诉，要求重审此案。法官裁定没有足够证据重审此案，但他们承认萨瓦尔在狱中受到了严重虐待。在随后的几年里，他又两次上诉以洗清罪名，均未成功。这个过程对萨瓦尔造成了沉重的打击，他酗酒过度、破产、与妻子分居，最终流落街头。他有一群相信他无罪的追随者，许多冰岛社区的人也改变了对他的看法。萨瓦尔·切萨尔斯基於2011年7月去世，享年56岁。
His funeral was packed with all walks of life to pay their respects, from high-ranking politicians to Saevar's family to his homeless friends. Following his death, Erla Bolladotta returned to the public eye. Still largely outcast by Icelandic society who thought of her as a conniving liar, Erla had moved to Hawaii with her daughter for a few years to escape. earlier, Erla had moved to Hawaii with her daughter for a few years to escape. The difference between life on a tropical island and the one she knew in Iceland was too great and she returned home. Following a particularly distressing incident where a member of the public came up and spat in her face, Erla pleaded for the case to be reopened. But with a lack of new evidence,
他的葬礼上挤满了社会各阶层的人来向他致敬，从高级政客到萨瓦尔的家人，再到他无家可归的朋友。在他去世后，埃尔拉·博拉多蒂尔重新回到了公众视野。埃尔拉仍然被认为是个诡计多端的骗子，大受冰岛社会的排挤，她曾带着女儿在夏威夷住了几年以求逃避。早些时候，埃尔拉曾带着女儿在夏威夷住了几年以求逃避。热带岛屿上的生活与她在冰岛熟悉的生活之间的差异太大了，她回到了家乡。在经历了一起特别令人痛苦的事件后——一名路人走过来吐口唾沫在她脸上，埃尔拉恳求重审此案。但由于缺乏新证据，
there was little that could be done. In May 2009, Christine Trygvedota held the hand of her dying father. Suffering from esophageal cancer, Trygve Leifsson had led a full life after his prison sentence. He had become a decorator, been married and had three children. Christine was close to her gentle and fun-loving dad who always had time for her. She remembered being called the daughter of a murderer by one of her school teachers as a small child, but looking at her father now, she knew it wasn't the truth. As she sat next to his hospital bed, she had something to confess to him. Christine told her father that when she was a teenager she had found some of his diaries
能做的事情微乎其微。2009年5月，克里斯汀·特里格维多蒂尔握着垂死父亲的手。特里格维·莱夫松患有食道癌，在刑满释放后，他过着充实的生活。他成为了一名装饰工，结了婚并育有三个孩子。克里斯汀与她这位温柔、风趣、总是抽出时间陪她的父亲十分亲密。她记得在小时候曾被一名学校老师称为杀人犯的女儿，但现在看着父亲，她知道这不是事实。当她坐在他的病床旁时，她有一些事情向他坦白。克里斯汀告诉父亲，当她还是个青少年时，她在地下室的一个盒子里发现了他的一些日记，
concealed in a box in the basement. Trygve knew of the diaries. He had filled books and books documenting his arrest and interrogation in Seathamooley Prison. A priest he had befriended in the prison smuggled them out and kept them until Trigvi was free. Trigvi thought he had burned all of the diaries long ago. Christine explained to him that she had taken a few and hidden them under her mattress, only daring to read them when she knew she was alone. He smiled, happy that she had read a part of his life he had kept so private from everyone. She asked her father what he wanted her to do with the diaries He told her to keep them, adding that she would know what to do with them when the time was right
被藏在地下室的一个盒子里。特里格维知道这些日记的事。他写了一本又一本的册子，记录了他在希特哈穆利监狱被捕和审讯的经历。他在狱中结交的一名牧师将这些日记偷运了出来，并一直替他保管，直到特里格维重获自由。特里格维以为自己早就把所有的日记都烧毁了。克里斯汀向他解释说，她拿了几本藏在床垫底下，只有在确信周围没人的时候才敢读。他笑了，为她读到了他向所有人严加保密的自己的人生片段而感到高兴。她问父亲想让她怎么处理这些日记。父亲告诉她把日记留着，并补充说，当时机成熟时，她会知道该怎么做。
A few days later, Trygve Leifsson passed away Two years later, in 2011, Christine showed the diaries to journalist Helga Arnadotter who was researching the case. Heart racing, she watched on as Helga leafed through the diaries. When she had finished, Helga told Christine she had something special. With Christine's permission, she contacted Geasley Gutjensen, a forensic psychologist and leading expert in false confessions Two days later, Helga and Christine knocked on the door of Geasley's home in South London Geasley studied the diaries cover to cover. The entries documented Trigvy's imprisonment in solitary confinement, his daily druggings with sedatives, and how he questioned his sanity. A common theme that arose was Trigvy's belief that if he confessed, his time in solitary confinement would be over.
几天后，特里格维·莱夫松逝世。两年后的2011年，克里斯汀将这些日记展示给了正在研究此案的记者海尔加·阿尔纳多蒂尔。她心跳加速，注视着海尔加翻阅日记。看完后，海尔加告诉克里斯汀她得到了非常特别的东西。在克里斯汀的允许下，她联系了法医心理学家、虚假供词领域的顶尖专家盖斯利·古德容森。两天后，海尔加和克里斯汀敲响了盖斯利位于伦敦南部家的大门。盖斯利通读了这些日记。日记记录了特里格维被单独监禁、每天被注射镇静剂以及他对理智产生怀疑的经历。其中出现的一个共同主题是，特里格维坚信只要自己招供，单独监禁的日子就会结束。
Trigvy thought he would have the chance to withdraw his confession, explain the truth at the trial, and he would be found a free man After studying the case further, Geasley could not believe the hours of interrogation the six accused had gone through without their lawyers present present. He formed the opinion that five of the accused had what he termed memory distrust syndrome, in which an individual does not trust their own memory and so comes to rely upon outside sources for information rather than using their own ability to recall facts. In the documentary Out of Thin Air, Geasley Gutjensen said, This is the only case I know of where so many individuals have had their memories distorted to this extent. They were just trying to appease the police. They were trying to be
特里格维以为他会有机会撤回供词，在审判时阐明真相，然后他就会被判无罪释放。在进一步研究该案后，盖斯利简直不敢相信六名被告在没有律师在场的情况下经历了长达数小时的审讯。他得出结论认为，五名被告患有他所谓的“记忆不信任综合征”，在这种综合征中，个人不相信自己的记忆，从而转而依赖外部来源获取信息，而不是依靠自己回忆事实的能力。在纪录片《无中生有》中，盖斯利·古德容森说：“据我所知，这是唯一一个有如此多人的记忆被扭曲到这种程度的案件。他们只是试图安抚警方。他们试图
cooperative because they knew if they were not cooperative, they would be given more solitary confinement. Christian Withersen looked forward to the times he would be sent to scour the desolate landscape to try and remember where the bodies of Gutmunder and Geirfinner Einarsson had been buried. The brief moment of freedom, despite grim, was a welcomed change to his time in prison. One time he was taken out of his cell was on January 23 1977. In a photo recovered from the police files, Christian can be seen in the lava fields wearing a melancholy expression with his left arm wrapped around a policeman's neck in a chokehold. expression, with his left arm wrapped around a policeman's neck in a chokehold. The policeman was pretending to be Geirfinner, with Christian re-enacting how he had incapacitated him.
表现得配合，因为他们知道如果不配合，就会被处以更多的单人禁闭。”克里斯蒂安·威瑟森很期待被派去荒凉的风景中搜寻，试图记起古德芒德尔和盖尔芬纳·埃纳尔松的尸体被埋在哪里的时候。尽管阴森恐怖，但短暂的自由对他在监狱里的生活来说是一个受欢迎的改变。他被带出牢房的一次是在1977年1月23日。在警察档案中恢复的一张照片中，克里斯蒂安出现在熔岩区，表情忧郁，左臂成扼喉状环绕着一名警察的脖子。表情忧郁，左臂成扼喉状环绕着一名警察的脖子。那名警察假装是盖尔芬纳，而克里斯蒂安则在重演他是如何使其失去自卫能力的。
Forensic psychologist Geisli Gutjensen noted the danger of re-enactments in an individual with memory distrust syndrome. Such acts might reinforce to the individual that the event actually occurred in that way. Armed with this information, journalist Helga Arnedotter compiled a special news report that ran on national television. Later that week, the Ministry of Justice announced a review of the case to look into the methods
法医心理学家盖斯利·古德容森指出，对患有记忆不信任综合征的个人进行重演具有潜在危险。这种行为可能会向当事人强化事件确实是以这种方式发生的印象。手头有了这些信息，记者海尔加·阿尔纳多蒂尔编纂了一篇在国家电视台播出的特别新闻报道。那周晚些时候，司法部宣布对该案进行审查，以调查案件中使用的
used in the investigation and how the confessions were obtained. It was quickly established that critical errors had been made in the course of the investigation, even though many of the police files relevant to the case were missing. Guards at Seatham-Uli Prison came forward with horror stories regarding what the six accused had been subjected to. One of the accused was hated by prison guards and officers in particular. Nicknamed the Rat by those in charge of his welfare, it was Saiba Cheselski. Often considered the ringleader of the group that murdered Guthmunder and Geirfinner, Saiba was subjected to brutal methods in order to obtain a confession. Along with being drugged with sedatives Mogadon, Diazepam and Chlorpromazine,
调查方法以及如何获得这些供词。很快人们就确定，在调查过程中犯下了重大错误，尽管许多与案件相关的警察档案已经丢失。希特哈穆利监狱的狱警们纷纷站出来，讲述了六名被告所遭受的恐怖经历。其中一名被告特别遭到狱警和官员的讨厌。由负责他福利的人给他取了个绰号叫“老鼠”，他就是赛巴·切舍尔斯基。赛巴常被认为是谋杀古德芒德尔和盖尔芬纳的团伙头目，为了逼供，他遭受了残酷的手段。除了被注射镇静剂美托拉宗、地西泮和氯丙嗪之外，
Saiba was subjected to sleep deprivation. An overhead light buzzed in his prison cell 24 hours a day, 7 days a week. While the rest of the cells had a period of lights out to mimic night, Cyber's remained on. He once tried to cover it with a woolen hat, but it was removed instantly. He once tried to cover it with a woolen hat, but it was removed instantly. When Saevar did drift off to sleep, guards would bang on his cell with steel chairs to rouse him. If he refused to answer questions, he was strangled by his shirt collar until he passed out. One day in July 1976, Saevar, who had a profound fear of water, was taken to the bathrooms of the prison. As water ran from one of the taps, filling a sink, Saevar had his head held underwater by guards who laughed to one another that they were drowning the rat.
赛巴还遭受了睡眠剥夺。他牢房里的头顶灯每周7天、每天24小时发出嗡嗡的响声。虽然其余的牢房都有熄灯时间来模仿夜晚，但赛巴的灯一直亮着。他曾试图用一顶羊毛帽盖住它，但立刻就被拿掉了。他曾试图用一顶羊毛帽盖住它，但立刻就被拿掉了。当赛巴确实迷迷糊糊睡着时，狱警会用钢椅猛击他的牢房来唤醒他。如果他拒绝回答问题，就会被勒住衬衫领子直到昏厥。1976年7的一天，对水有着极度恐惧的赛巴被带到了监狱的浴室。当水从水龙头流出、装满洗手池时，赛巴的头被狱警按在水下，狱警们互相嘲笑说他们在淹死这只老鼠。
Completely broken and in a vulnerable state, Siver confessed to the murders. Detectives took Siver to the sites where he claimed to have buried the bodies. His inability to find them was seen as him deliberately obstructing the investigation rather than him not knowing. While other inmates were allowed books, pens, tobacco and newspapers,
彻底崩溃且处于脆弱状态的赛巴承认了谋杀。侦探将赛巴带到他声称埋葬尸体的地点。他无法找到尸体被认为是他故意阻挠调查，而不是他不知道。当其他犯人被允许拥有书籍、钢笔、烟草和报纸时，
Cyber was denied. The guards reasoned that he should instead sit and think about his actions. He was also denied visits from family. The other five accused also suffered from isolation and a lack of human interaction, which had a profound effect on their mental wellbeing. Christian wrote in his diary in prison, There was nothing but waiting, waiting for the next interrogation, wondering what I would say. interrogation, wondering what I would say. In the cell I could do nothing but think. I grew into the walls. I could not feel my body. I was just a head.
赛巴却被剥夺了这些权利。狱警认为他应该坐下来反思自己的行为。他还被拒绝家人探视。其他五名被告也遭受了隔离和缺乏人际交往的痛苦，这对他们的心理健康产生了深远的影响。克里斯蒂安在监狱日记中写道：“除了等待，没有别的，等待下一次审讯，想知道我会说些什么。等待下一次审讯，想知道我会说些什么。在牢房里，我什么也做不了，只能思考。我长进了墙里。我感觉不到自己的身体。我只剩下一个脑袋。”
Two times while awaiting trial, Christian tried to take his own life. Trigvi recounted a similar feeling in his diary, stating, I've got so many drugs, so much medication that I can't remember my name. I wake up and I can't remember if my mother passed away or if I was dreaming it. The thoughts of reuniting with her baby were the only thing getting Erla through her isolation. She told the documentary, out of thin air, I wasn't allowed to go outside. I was in complete isolation. Very soon, you shrink down into this helpless baby and you're in this abstract world. I thought to myself, did I really even have a baby? Or is that my imagination also?
在等待审判期间，克里斯蒂安曾两次试图自杀。特里格维在日记中讲述了类似的感觉，他写道：“我服用了太多的药，太多的药物，以至于我想不起自己的名字。我醒来时想不起母亲是已经过世了，还是我在做梦。”与孩子团聚的想法是支撑埃尔拉度过隔离期的唯一动力。她在纪录片《无中生有》中说道：“我不被允许外出。我处于完全隔离状态。很快，你就会缩成这个无助的婴儿，你在这个抽象的世界里。我心里想，我真的生过孩子吗？还是那也是我的想象？”
Cause I swear that I feel like I do. But no pictures coming. You can't trust your own mind. your own mind. In the book The Reykjavik Confessions, Erla detailed one night where she was raped by a policeman in her cell. The policeman put his hand over her mouth to stop her calling out while he lay on top of her on her prison bed. When he finished and prepared to leave, he told her that he was taking great risks by being a friend to her and she should be grateful By the time Erla found the courage to speak up about the event, the statute of limitations had expired and it was too late for her to press charges
因为我发誓我感觉我有。但没有画面出现。你不能相信自己的心智。你不能相信自己的心智。在《雷克雅未克供词》一书中，埃尔拉详细描述了一个晚上，她在牢房里被一名警察强奸。那名警察把手捂在她的嘴上，以阻止她喊叫，同时压在她牢房的床上。当他完事准备离开时，他告诉她，作为她的朋友，他冒了很大的风险，她应该心存感激。等埃尔拉鼓起勇气说出这件事时，诉讼时效已经过期，她再起诉已经太迟了
Erla was also subjected to what was called a memory injection by police detectives under the instruction of Detective Carl Schutz to try and jog her memory of what had happened in the events of Geirfinner's death Under the effects of the drug, Erla admitted that she had made up what had happened from what she had read in newspapers and twisted the facts to create a story that was entirely false Erla admitted that she had made up what had happened from what she had read in newspapers and twisted the facts to create a story that was entirely false. The detectives believed that she had been receiving inside information from Saevar, who was telling her what to say, and refused to believe her. believe her. On March 23 2013, the committee into the case of what has been termed the Reykjavik confessions presented their findings. The key finding was that the confessions, in all likelihood, were fabricated. The committee recommended that the state prosecutor reopen the case.
在警探卡尔·舒茨（Detective Carl Schutz）的指示下，埃尔拉（Erla）还接受了所谓的记忆注射，警探企图借此唤醒她对盖尔芬纳（Geirfinnur）死亡事件经过的记忆。在药物的作用下，埃尔拉承认，她所说的一切都是根据她在报纸上读到的内容编造的，并扭曲了事实，编造了一个完全虚假的故事。埃尔拉承认，她所说的一切都是根据她在报纸上读到的内容编造的，并扭曲了事实，编造了一个完全虚假的故事。警探们认为她一直在接受塞瓦尔（Saevar）内部消息的提供，塞瓦尔一直在告诉她该说些什么，并拒绝相信她。相信她。2013年3月23日，针对被称为“雷克雅未克供词”（Reykjavik confessions）一案的委员会提交了调查结果。核心调查结果是，这些供词在极大的可能性上是伪造的。委员会建议国家检察官重新审理此案。
Five and a half years later, Erla Bolledotter and the families of Saevar Trzeszelski and Trygve Leifsson sat amongst the crowded courtroom in Reykjavik. Collectively, they held their breath as the verdict was read. 44 years after the disappearances of Gutmunder and Geirfinn-Erinnesen, Saebertrischelski, Christian Bitherson, Trigby Leifsson, Gutjonskap-Jadensen and Albert Skaftersen were found not guilty in the murders and disposal of the two men. In an unusual turn of events, both the prosecution and the defence demanded they be acquitted. It was a bittersweet moment for the families
五年半后，埃尔拉·博利多蒂尔（Erla Bolledotter）以及塞瓦尔·特热热尔斯基（Saevar Trzeszelski）和特里格维·莱夫松（Trygve Leifsson）的家人们坐在挤满人的雷克雅未克法庭里。在宣读判决时，他们集体屏住了呼吸。在古德蒙德（Gudmundur）和盖尔芬纳-埃里内森（Geirfinn-Erinnesen）失踪44年后，塞瓦尔·特里热尔斯基（Saebertrischelski）、克里斯蒂安·比特森（Christian Bitherson）、特里格维·莱夫松（Trigby Leifsson）、古德永·斯卡普-雅登森（Gutjonskap-Jadensen）和阿尔伯特·斯卡夫特森（Albert Skaftersen）被判谋杀和处理两名男子尸体的罪名不成立。在一个不同寻常的转折中，控辩双方都要求判处他们无罪。对两人的家属来说，这是一个苦乐参半的时刻
of Saevar and Trygve, knowing that they weren't alive to see justice done. Erla Bolledotter did not have her name cleared in relation to the perjury of the Kluberan IV. Some argued that she should be acquitted given that the whole case was built on falsified confessions. She held her head high and returned to her job as a language teacher, helping those who recently migrated to Iceland to learn the language. 46 years after their disappearances, the case of Gudmundur and Geirfinnur Einarsson is as well known today amongst Icelanders as it was then. Despite the passage of time, new leads occasionally trickle into police.
塞瓦尔和特里格维深知他们活着时未能看到正义得到伸张。埃尔拉·博利多蒂尔（Erla Bolledotter）的名字并未洗清，这与克卢贝兰四世（Kluberan IV）的作伪证罪有关。一些人认为，鉴于整个案件建立在伪造的口供之上，她应当被判无罪。她高昂着头，重操旧业，继续做她的语言老师，帮助那些最近移民到冰岛的人学习冰岛语。在他们失踪46年后的今天，古德蒙德（Gudmundur）和盖尔芬纳·埃纳尔松（Geirfinnur Einarsson）一案在冰岛人中依然像当年一样广为人知。尽管时光流逝，新的线索偶尔仍会传入警方耳中。
Despite the passage of time, new leads occasionally trickle into police. In 2015, Stefan Almason was questioned by police after testimony from Stefan's ex-girlfriend shed new light on Gutmunde's disappearance. Stefan was already known in the case. In the early days of the investigation he was questioned and told police he thought that Saiba and Christian were responsible for Guthmunder's disappearance. For the sake of clarity, we will refer to Stefan's ex-girlfriend as Helga. Helga came forward to say that she was a passenger in Stefan's vehicle the night Gutmunder went missing. According to Helga, the car struck Gutmunder while he was walking down the road.
尽管时光流逝，新的线索偶尔仍会传入警方耳中。2015年，在史蒂芬（Stefan）的前女友提供证词、为古德蒙德的失踪案带来新线索后，史蒂芬·阿尔马松（Stefan Almason）受到了警方的盘问。史蒂芬在此案中早已为人所知。在调查的初期，他曾接受过盘问，并告诉警方，他认为塞巴（Saiba）和克里斯蒂安（Christian）对古德蒙德的失踪负有责任。为了表达清晰，我们将史蒂芬的前女友称为赫尔加（Helga）。赫尔加挺身而出称，古德蒙德失踪当晚，她是史蒂芬车上的乘客。据赫尔加回忆，当古德蒙德正在路上行走时，汽车撞上了他。
She, along with Stefan and his friend Thorður Æðursson, helped Gutmunder into the car. He thanked them for picking him up. Helga was then dropped off home. As she left the vehicle, Gutmunder was visibly suffering from the collision. Blood was coming out of his ear and nose. That was the last time Helga saw him. Both Stefan and Thortha denied these allegations wholeheartedly. Both Stefan and Thorður denied these allegations wholeheartedly. With no forensic evidence to prove the accusations, the investigation was dropped. According to the Iceland Review, in 2016 a man contacted the police to say he had been
她与史蒂芬以及他的朋友索尔杜尔·埃杜尔松（Thorður Æðursson）一起，将古德蒙德扶上了车。古德蒙德感谢他们搭载了他。随后，赫尔加被送到家中。当她离开汽车时，古德蒙德明显因碰撞而痛苦不堪。他的耳鼻都在流血。那是赫尔加最后一次见到他。史蒂芬和索尔塔都对这些指控予以了坚决否认。史蒂芬和索尔杜尔都对这些指控予以了坚决否认。由于没有法医证据来证明这些指控，调查最终被撤销。据《冰岛评论》（Iceland Review）报道，2016年，一名男子联系警方称，他一直
holding onto information since Geirfinnur's disappearance. For the sake of clarity, we will refer to this witness as Jón. Jón claimed that the day after Geirfinnur went missing, he and his girlfriend were at Vestmaneja. The small island was 190 kilometres east of Keblavik, where Gayabina's car was found. The couple witnessed three men dressed in civilian clothing arrive on a small boat and make their way to a fish processing plant on the island. The man in the middle of the three seemed weak and appeared to be losing consciousness. As Jan and his partner walked past, the man in the middle allegedly said, Remember me. Shortly after, the men boarded another boat. Jan watched as the three men
自盖尔芬纳（Geirfinnur）失踪以来，他一直保留着一些信息。为了表达清晰，我们将这位证人称为容（Jón）。容声称，在盖尔芬纳失踪的第二天，他和女友在韦斯特曼纳埃亚尔（Vestmaneja）。这个小岛位于加亚比纳（Gayabina）汽车被发现的凯布拉维克（Keblavik）以东190公里处。这对情侣目睹了三名身着便服的男子乘坐一艘小船抵达，并前往岛上的一家鱼类加工厂。三人中间的那名男子显得十分虚弱，似乎快要失去意识。当扬（Jan）和他的伴侣走过时，中间的那名男子据称说道：“记住我。”不久之后，这几名男子登上了另一艘船。扬看着这三名男子
went out to sea. He saw the boat return to the shore again, but only two men came back. returned to the shore again, but only two men came back. Two days later, his girlfriend received an anonymous call stating that she and her boyfriend would be killed if they spoke of what they saw. As those come forward offering theories as to what did happen to Gudmundur and Geirfinnur, so do those working to bolster the innocence of those accused of their murders. At the time of Gudmundur's disappearance, the phone at Erla's apartment was disconnected due to an unpaid phone bill. This was confirmed by the Icelandic Telephone Company
驶向大海。他看到那艘船再次返回岸边，但只有两名男子回来了。再次返回岸边，但只有两名男子回来了。两天后，他的女友接到一个匿名电话，称如果他们敢说出看到的事情，她和她的男友就会被杀害。正当人们纷纷站出来提出关于古德蒙德和盖尔芬纳究竟发生了什么的各种理论时，也有人站出来努力巩固那些被指控谋杀他们的人的清白。在古德蒙德失踪之时，埃尔拉公寓的电话因未付话费而被停机。这一点得到了冰岛电话公司的证实
and meant that Saevar couldn't have used it to phone Albert to pick up Gudmundur's body. Furthermore, the yellow Toyota that Albert Skaftason said belonged to his father that was used to dump the body of Gudmundur was not owned by his father at the time of Gudmundur's disappearance. Albert said he watched from his rearview mirror as Saevar, Christian and Trygve put the body in the boot of the car. At the time, Albert's father drove a tiny Volkswagen Beetle. The boot was at the front of the car. From the book Out of Thin Air, in 2016 journalist Jan Danielsson looked into Saevar's alibi at the time of Geirfinnur's disappearance
这意味着塞瓦尔不可能用这台电话打给阿尔伯特去接古德蒙德的尸体。此外，阿尔伯特·斯卡夫塔松（Albert Skaftason）所说属于他父亲、并被用于抛弃古德蒙德尸体的黄色丰田汽车，在古德蒙德失踪时并不属于他的父亲。阿尔伯特说，他从后视镜里看着塞瓦尔、克里斯蒂安和特里格维把尸体放进汽车的后备箱。当时，阿尔伯特父亲开的是一辆微型大众甲壳虫汽车。后备箱位于汽车的前部。据2016年出版的书籍《凭空消失》（Out of Thin Air）记载，记者扬·丹尼尔松（Jan Danielsson）调查了盖尔芬纳失踪时塞瓦尔的不在场证明
Saevar had given this information to the judges at the trial, however it was not investigated further Saevar alleged he had gone to his mother's house to watch television. Saevar remembered the show. It was a news report about a company in France guilty of tampering with red wine. Jan Danielsen looked through the archives for the television guide for that night. There was a news report from France titled Winegate, which finished at 11pm, when Saevar was allegedly with Geovina at the Keblavik docks. Prior to his arrest, Gutjonskap Hjelmtsson kept newspaper clippings and notes about the Gayafina case in a small book in his study.
塞瓦尔在审判时曾向法官提供过这一信息，但并未得到进一步调查。塞瓦尔声称他去了母亲家看电视。塞瓦尔还记得那个节目。那是一则关于法国一家公司涉嫌在红酒中掺假的电视新闻报道。扬·丹尼尔森（Jan Danielsen）查阅了当晚的电视节目指南档案。档案中有一则来自法国、名为《红酒门》（Winegate）的新闻报道，该报道于晚上11点结束，当时塞瓦尔据称正与盖奥维纳（Geovina）在凯布拉维克码头。在被捕之前，古德永斯卡普·海尔姆特松（Gutjonskap Hjelmtsson）在书房的一个小本子里保存着有关加亚费纳（Gayafina）案的剪报和笔记。
When it was found in a search by police, he explained that after being questioned in May 1976 as an acquaintance of Saevar's, he decided to take notes and keep up to date with the case. Detective Karl Schütz thought it was so he could construct the perfect alibi if he were ever arrested A theory that fell through as Guthion could give no alibi for the night in question In his first diary entry in prison dated November 18 1976, Guthion wrote I know nothing about this case. Sometimes I feel guilty, that I'm guilty of something, but I can't remember what happened.
当警方在搜查中发现这个本子时，他解释说，在1976年5月作为塞瓦尔的熟人接受盘问后，他决定做笔记并随时关注案件的最新进展。警探卡尔·舒茨（Karl Schütz）则认为，这是为了让他在一旦被捕时能够构建出完美的不在场证明。然而这一理论最终破产，因为古德永（Guthion）无法为案发当晚提供任何不在场证明。在他于1976年11月18日写下的第一篇监狱日记中，古德永写道：“我对这个案子一无所知。有时候我感到内疚，觉得自己犯了什么罪，但我记不清发生了什么。”
This is taking away all of my strength. I must be ill. Two days later he wrote, New humiliation, disgrace and shame. "'I, who lived in the belief in the two years previously "'that I knew nothing about the matter, "'and now I have been involved in it. "'Am I insane, or have I been there?
这带走了我全部的力量。我一定是生病了。两天后他写道：“新的屈辱、耻辱和羞愧。‘我，曾在前两年深信不疑，‘我对这件事一无所知，‘而现在我却被卷入了其中。‘我是疯了，还是我曾去过那里？”
"'I say yes to that. "'Much of what I have done in recent years was insanity." Erla continues to try and explain what led to her confessing to a crime she didn't commit. In the book The Reykjavik Confessions, she says, The detectives would explain that we needed to get the confession done or I was risking that I would lose my child and they didn't want to see that happen. Somewhere, I always knew it didn't happen. So I really needed to believe that it had happened, and they kept throwing me something to help me believe it." On January 29 2020, the State Treasury dispensed the total of 815 million Icelandic krona, the equivalent of nearly 8.2 million Australian dollars, to Christian, Albert, Gutjohn and
‘我对此表示赞同。‘我近年来的所作所为，很大程度上都是疯狂的。’埃尔拉继续试图解释是什么导致她承认了一项自己并未犯下的罪行。她在《雷克雅未克供词》（The Reykjavik Confessions）一书中说道：“警探们会解释说，我们需要完成口供，否则我将面临失去孩子的风险，他们不想看到这种事发生。在内心深处，我知道事情并未发生。所以我真的很需要去相信它确实发生了，而他们不断给我提供一些东西来帮我相信这一点。”2020年1月29日，国家财政部向克里斯蒂安、阿尔伯特、古德约翰（Gutjohn）以及
the families of Saevar and Tryggvi as compensation for their wrongful conviction and imprisonment. In the course of the investigation, Saevar Ciesielski spent 615 days in solitary confinement. During that time, he was interrogated 180 times for a total of 340 hours until he confessed to the crimes to end his solitary confinement. Erla Bolledotter spent 241 days in solitary confinement and was interrogated 105 times until she confessed to her involvement. She is still campaigning to have her perjury conviction overturned. Trigvi Leifsson spent the most time in solitary confinement at a total of 655 days, the longest recorded period of solitary confinement endured by someone outside of Guantanamo Bay.
塞瓦尔和特里格维的家人们发放了总计8.15亿冰岛克朗（约合近820万澳大利亚元）的赔偿金，作为对他们被错误定罪和监禁的赔偿。在调查过程中，塞瓦尔·谢谢尔斯基（Saevar Ciesielski）在单人禁闭室度过了615天。在此期间，他被审讯了180次，总计340小时，直到他承认了罪行以结束单人监禁。埃尔拉·博利多蒂尔（Erla Bolledotter）在单人禁闭室度过了241天，被审讯了105次，直到她承认了自己的参与。她目前仍在积极奔走，试图推翻对其作伪证的定罪。特里格维·莱夫松（Trigvi Leifsson）在单人禁闭室度过的时间最长，总计655天，这是关塔那摩湾以外的人所经历的有记录的最长的单人禁闭期。
His diaries, later taken by his daughter Christine, were titled This is a diary that an innocent man is keeping in here regarding a big case that he is wrongly accused for, but the truth will always come out, even if it is late. An entry dated April 25 1977 read An entry dated April 25 1977 read, So now, I have been here continuously for 16 months and 11 days in custody, including 14 months in isolation, totally alone. I shall hold fast.
他的日记后来被他的女儿克里斯蒂娜（Christine）拿走，日记标题为：“这是一名无辜男子在这里关于一个他被错误指控的大案所记的日记，但真相终将大白于天下，哪怕来得有些迟。”一篇日期为1977年4月25日的日记写道：一篇日期为1977年4月25日的日记写道：“所以现在，我已经在羁押中连续度过了16个月零11天，其中14个月是在完全孤立的隔离中度过的。我将坚守到底。”
I don't have to be afraid, as I'm innocent, and justice always prevails in the end. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我无需害怕，因为我是无辜的，正义终究会战胜一切。谢谢。该剧集目前尚无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。